what's up everyone this is Anthony
papiano most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the chains
simply the best podcasting crypto let's
kick this thing off Shriram krishnan is
a longtime friend and currently focused
on more writing and investing in
early-stage companies we've previously
worked together at Facebook where we
both led product teams the Shriram later
went on to be a senior product lead at
both snapchat and Twitter in this
conversation we discussed his time
growing up in India how he met his wife
on yahoo messenger what he learned from
Mark Zuckerberg Evan Spiegel and Jack
Dorsey why organizations are systems
where his obsession with memos came from
and who the greatest basketball player
of all time is this conversation was a
lot of fun and we dug deep into a number
of fascinating topics that I think you
will enjoy all right guys bang bang I
have a special treat for you today
Shriram is here we were just joking
about he is the only person that has
worked at two companies that I've worked
at and I think he's the only person that
I'd directly worked with that Facebook
has been on a podcast those were very
fun days so we got a lot to talk about
thanks for coming to do this thanks for
having me
and I hope you Argon's is prepared for
all the embarrassing pomp stories all
right you've got probably one of the
most fascinating stories in technology
that I know of you were born in India
and then you end up working at Facebook
snapchat and Twitter all in pretty
important leadership roles how do we get
from India to Silicon Valley up other
than to get him on a plane at some point
I just got lucky a bunch of times you
know it's really hot I think sometimes
when you look at this a post fact you
you build an attitude for yourself and
you try and connect the dots but each of
those was random and serendipitous like
a lot of people I was born in in China
in India it's a sleepy little city in
the south of India which is not
surprising there's a lot of tech people
coming from it like soon dollars from
there there are many other folks from
there convinced my dad when I was in
high school to buy me a computer which
is a fairly big
deal for him maybe expensive and I had
to convince him that it would be
productive and I taught myself how to
code I was not very social I just kind
of sat at home every single night and
there was I couldn't Billy offered
dial-up internet most days so I would
just you know open up a visual basic
book or a c-plus way I just taught
myself what a good really liked it and
once you know I went to college I would
start writing things online and I think
I was lucky to be the recipient of
multiple big breaks we just happen to me
senator participe and in college I had
my first big one where well I think the
biggest one was I met my now wife back
all the way back in college we have
known each other for like you know it's
1718 years now and I'm gonna tell you a
sentence which doesn't mean what do you
think it means we met online and the
story is and it's not because we swiped
on each other we back in 2002 we had a
friend who wanted to build a website he
did not know how to write code he added
the two nerdiest frenzy new on yahoo
chat room so this really does how all
this story is back in Yahoo Chatham sort
of thing and we're supposed to the site
the site never got built but we would
chat with each other every night from
like 11 p.m. to like far away and we
just chat we didn't even know how each
other look like you guys had never met
each other in person no never you mean
now formally two people were you and
your wife yes ah and we just chatted
every night and after year we met in
person and that's how we became friends
so and where she was at the same school
Oh difference he was a different City
yeah we are from the same city but she
was going to school in a different city
and so we were just like only dressing
for a year where the our message so but
back then you know I was starting to
write blog online I would write about
micro technologies and this is my first
big break where at the time you know
Microsoft was punching Visual Studio
Express which was meant to be in
addition meant for students and what
they would do is they would do this
conference and they'd send an exact and
they were a keynote demo and what they
would get a local student to come on
stage and to compile hello world and to
be like tada I know you Western can use
it too but the Microsoft India team
didn't really know many students at the
time and because of some stuff I had
written online somebody send me a cold
email from Microsoft saying hey would
you like to come
or to Banglore and then do this thing
and at the time you know I was you know
sitting in my bedroom in Chennai and
never been on a flight before I was like
great I did this demo for this VP and at
the end of it and my by now wife RT but
she was also there and he said you kids
should come work at Microsoft I was like
well great but we live in like nowhere
land and you might have seen a different
galaxy
yeah and long story short he put us in
touch with recruiting at Microsoft and
we became like product managers there so
okay so when you first get introduced to
the recruiters at Microsoft are they
immediately vetting you as potential
employees or is there like you guys like
hey how does this work like we had a
weird experience because you know the
exact we met who so much Seguros know a
fantastic VC at madrone ventures he
actually invested it he put in money in
my wife's company ten years later so
it's kind of thinks it's great full
circle he he didn't know who to send a
couple of random kids to it was not his
purview so he put us in touch with you
know the folks who do care with a lot of
these sort of senior people recruiting
or exactly creating at Microsoft and so
we kind of had this weird alternate
interview loop I think at the time they
were not really hiring a many product
managers or program managers Mike so
called out of college so we kind of had
this bizarre Luke where they went like
oh we don't really know what to do with
these two let's get them in and then
they hired us and so that is kind of my
that's kind of our big break into tech
so got into Microsoft and in India or
coming to CRO
in India for a short time but flew to
Seattle a couple of years in and have
been your us ever since and for the
first five years of Microsoft I work
mostly on cloud computing so before
Windows Azure was named Windows Azure it
was this side little skunkworks project
for Microsoft which was kind of a bunch
of crazy data center distributed
computing people and at the time of
really interested in distributed
computing I had written my own version
of paxos and you know the Byzantine
general problem solutions that I was
into space so I basically knocked on the
door and I said hey I would love to work
on this you know whatever you want me to
do so I I was very lucky to be there
right place join as a p.m. spent five
years there on Windows Azure through the
launch was a fantastic experience
because you got to see this company
really okay how would we compete with
Amazon hard with a cloud platform
Mike's was fantastic but both Artie on
my wife Artie and I we logged Silicon
Valley you know our first date was to
watch a hoping audience trouble a
BitTorrent ed copy of pirates of Silicon
Valley I didn't like either 2002 by the
way still the best Steve Jobs movie of
all time
I and we were just these random kids you
know being like someday we want to be
that I know it sounds like we share but
it was yeah and in 2011 we got our green
cards and became permanent as new United
States which is a big deal because this
meant that you know we could actually
leave Microsoft and go do other things
start companies without a whole amount
of paperwork which is it was really hard
if you had not a permit it's not a
citizen and so we classed Microsoft had
a long chat with like Satya you know who
was working for at the time and said
we're gonna go do this thing came down
to the Bay Area and we looked at each
other and said look there are two of us
one of us should do that crazy startup
you know and one of us should get a job
which pays a paycheck so our theme or a
wife you know it's still the amazing
founder and entrepreneur the family you
know she went off to launch two startups
one of which you know she went to Y
Combinator I believe she was a this
summer or winter 13 she launches
ecommerce company called lumoid they did
a fantastic five-year run they stole a
couple of years ago and she know by
their works at Facebook but me back in
2012 I was like well one of us she's
doing off they're building a company but
she was kind of shipping box or a
bedroom and being really scrappy and I
should get a good job and I had a lot of
friends had gone from Microsoft to
Facebook at the time and this is a very
interesting time for Facebook because
Facebook had just gone public and if you
remember the stock was getting crushed
I think their IPO at around 50 down like
22 or something 20 times faster I mean
it didn't even played for the first few
hours and because I think but the deeper
question was people are asking where
look all of your traffic is switching
over to mobile you know you could see
the numbers you could see the writing on
the wall
I think the wall was already here
but all of your monetization was still
dominantly
and what on web right you know this I
mean you were there and so the big
question that market had for face was
like can you monetize mobile can anyone
marked ice mold no of course but in now
in sitting here in 2020 this all sounds
crazy and silly but that was the big
question then and at the time you know I
told myself in a look Facebook I want to
work on consumer apps I work on data
centers but I want to work on take a
look consumer Larsson Facebook knew felt
like they knew something which rest the
world didn't and I wanted to go learn
that and once a drawing Facebook as a
p.m. I told my so I know nothing about
mobile I don't nothing about advertising
so let me go work in the space so this
was probably the second like luckiest
thing I ever did outside of the
Microsoft job because it was absolutely
you know early 2013 working on mobile
ads inside Facebook was the perfect
right time right place you know I just
got very very lucky yeah you know that
you were there well and so a lot of
people don't know this story because
this isn't like the sexy story of
Facebook through those years but you
joined in beginning of 13
give or take I joined the beginning of
14 and we both worked on the ads team
doing different things but but I
remember going to meetings and the
people that I remember being in the room
specifically are you Michael Sharon Mike
you deck boss you know all these people
who now have gone on to either do
different things or or you know continue
to do great things at Facebook and I
remember looking around the room
sometimes in being like holy [ __ ] right
like there's a lot of smart people in
this room who are the best in the world
at what they're working on and the story
that I always tell people is the first
time I ever saw an ads is going bananas
sign inside and so for those that don't
know what that means if you think of the
shape of a banana it looks like every
startup graph right it just goes up into
the right well the thing at Facebook was
it was literally growing so fast in
terms of that revenue the mobile ads etc
that literally it looked like it was
bending backwards on itself it was just
explosive growth and so it's just a
really
cool thing to live through and kind of
experience alongside so many great
people
it was and honestly it was each of these
things you can only look back in
retrospect and be like well I was very
lucky I could've tried a different
company I could've picked a different
team and I would have missed out so you
know I can't claim I was you know Samos
why I just was in the right time right
place but I think if you look back then
you know today Facebook art seemed like
you know this huge dominant in a amazing
platform but back then you know on
mobile ads and Facebook we we look at
Google and we were like wow we have this
huge mountain to climb and we were still
building the basics if we were still
building the basics of targeting the
basics of measurement the basics of how
you know the ad auctions work we can
even get ad to show up on mobile feed
properly for a while
so because I think now you know Facebook
is such a it seems the incumbent in
power but back then it wasn't a given
you know we were just like a bunch of
people and we knew everyone a small
group of people who we all fit the
conference room yes yeah the most part
like my cue deck sat in the corner I'm
gonna calm out right now and he would
sit up on the filing cabinet right with
his microphone and the other 25 30
people would sit in the room and
everyone that that was it it was and and
I think I still think I probably learned
the most interesting lessons in those
viewers at Facebook when were there less
is he learned or took away um it's
interesting so I have this you know this
weird trajectory because I've been in
like you know Facebook snap and Twitter
which a lot of people think of as a kind
of being similar in some way and so I
have this interesting trajectory where I
often see in the same decisions happen
and see how they are discussed or talked
about in three different companies and
you may not say this but I'll say this
you also have had the opportunity to
work pretty closely in most cases with
Sasha and Microsoft suck at Facebook
Evan Spiegel at snapchat and then jacket
Twitter so it's not just oh I worked at
this company it's these decisions are
being debated at the highest levels of
each one of those businesses and you've
been there to see others yeah so you
know if you want to jump into that I
think you know one thing I found is you
know when I was at sake I was like wait
you know in the stack I would but with
these three one thing you realize is
each of them are incredibly smart you
know in the top if you talk to them you
just you quickly realize why they are in
the position they are yep but they're
also incredibly different and if you
look at these three companies one thing
I realize is one there are many many
ways to build a fantastic great company
and 3t each company is a reflection of
the founder and some of the core values
at the founder holds dear so let's look
at Facebook I think as either if you
look at the lessons from Facebook items
that are mini but I think off top my
head and I think this I would love to
get your take on it is one is optimizing
for impact you know Facebook or mini Oh
probably over everything else will pick
impact so what does that mean it means
that in any decision you make in any
product decision or hiring position or
anything you do you ask yourself like
what is the most impactful way to go
about this for example back in 2007-2008
when Facebook was thinking of growing
there were many paths for them to grow
they had grown in the u.s. you know they
could have picked the next country and
grown going after and gone after them
but at the time you know the growth team
looked at and said well the most
impactful thing for us to do would be to
go after everyone who doesn't speak
English and that led to the creation of
you know the translation project existed
then so it's just definitely a mindset
of always asking yourself what is the
most impactful thing that you can do and
that story was always interesting when
we were there because they didn't start
out with like what most companies would
do what most companies did go hire a
bunch of people who speak you know
Russian Chinese whatever languages
instead they just said hey we've got
tens of millions hundreds of millions of
people using this site anybody who
speaks Russian who would like to help
translate our site from English to
Russian here's some tools to do that
right and go back to the impact it was
like if you go and you hire you know
Russian translators and it's very kind
of centralized and methodical to take a
long time to get to the impact in terms
of just kind of open sourcing to some
degree tools that then allow people to
help quickly translate the website now
you get a
different languages all at the same time
much quicker and so it's not only just
like where is the most impact also
what's the straightest line - yes which
i think is the second part of what
Facebook's so effective is a focus on
speed and iteration um somebody at
Facebook was very senior once told me
that he's never should face we'll get it
right at first but they're gonna it
probably gonna be the fastest at
iterating and getting to the right
answer the quickest and I think he sees
all time where Facebook builds both
technological and cultural missionary to
focus on speed so you know when they
launch this translation product they it
probably wasn't perfect but they knew
they could make it better very very
quickly like we saw this when we did ads
when we launched you know the original
version of the Facebook ad products it
didn't have a lot of features that
Google had or the competition had but
Facebook got so much better so quickly
and I think one of the lessons I learned
there is I think it's very easy often to
psych yourself out of launching
something or to say I'm gonna wait until
I get everything right I mean I
understand our every single like I and T
but Facebook like look they just go get
something out the door build the muscle
to go execute and iterate very quickly
and you will wind up beating the
competition so I think it's a very
particular mindset now it has its
downsides which you know I think we know
so famously know but I think that was
like such a key cultural attribute for
them tell the story of the mobile ad
network because what you guys yeah when
you guys built in March that it went
from zero to a billion dollars in
revenue in 18 months I think yes right
yeah thanks yeah so see the back story
then is you know Facebook at the time
was trying to figure out if they had an
interesting problem they had they were
in the ad tech world that this place is
a PU is called being supplied
constrained and being demand country and
what this means when a supply
constrained is you know you have a lot
of me people giving you money but you
don't have you know enough space to show
them and if your demand constrained you
a lot of place to show these ads we
don't have any people giving you money
and Facebook went through a very
interesting transition in around 2011
2012 you know they had a lot of you know
space to show ads in but didn't have
enough people giving the money they were
demand constraint so that's why they
launched the bidder Facebook exchange
the
probably will interest into this you
know the attic population they just they
launched a lot of products to try to
drive more demand hey we've all this
space but no one wants to advertise yet
let's do things to get a lot of people
who want advertising exactly but things
change very quickly but they were very
good at getting demand yes you'll be
like oh my gosh we we have a lot of
demand and we don't know where to put
the ads and I remember I'm this like you
know probably 78 years ago so I'm gonna
get in trouble at one time we look at
the numbers we like what we're spinning
less than 10% of the money they're
advertisers want to spend on it's like
people are basing like spin I won't
spend hundreds with you Facebook could
only spend like eight or nine dollars or
$500 and so there's this question of
well how do you actually go show these
ads and you have to be smart about it
because you know the easiest answer
would be to say why don't you show more
ads to everyone but you know as we all
know like you know the more you show the
more you risk annoying people the more
you liske you know losing your best you
know most valuable customers off the
platform and so you have to figure out
well and if you want to show an ad let
us say for Nike and I'm a big sneaker
person so you want to show me an ad for
Nike you have to know that I'm really
interested in sneakers that it is a
fantastic ad and make that match the
exact right time and space so circa 2013
we had run out of space you know we had
shown on all the ads we could in feed at
the time and we're trying to figure what
to do I remember literally being in
those meetings and Rob would say winter
is coming yes right ever that was the
big mantra which was essentially saying
all of the ads were going into newsfeed
but there was only you know every feed
load basically time you refresh there's
like six or seven ads and we they were
sold out every time and there were still
more demand there's like it's like what
having a business with a line around the
corner and you're like we gotta have
more supply because we gotta feed all
these people who want the food right yes
and and so there was this come this hunt
to go figure out like where do we show
these ads and you know one obvious
answer was like well why don't we show
these ads outside Facebook and this was
not a novel idea like Google had you
know ad networks have been around for a
very long period of time Google
obviously had at the time the dominant
market leader with Google Adsense but we
said well we should take a stab at it
and in the past Facebook could not take
a stab at it because they didn't have a
line on the door but now they did so you
know and me
a few others we kind of put this effort
together it's called the Facebook
audience Network where we said look
where is Facebook really strong like
we're strong on mobile we are strong
inside apps and we're also really good
at showing ads which look and feel like
they should fit within the app you know
because ads the time where these big
banners which would kind of like you
know slide up or they would slide in and
they were annoying they were not fun and
Facebook had really discovered like how
to show ads I mean feed natively which
felt a part of the experience and we
said what if we can do that for everyone
so we built a steam and you know it was
again like right time right place no we
were able to scale it up very quickly
because it turned out that there were a
lot of people on mobile you know um
publishers like for example media
companies which which are mobile but
they weren't making a lot of money or
they were gaming companies who had some
paying customers but that wasn't enough
to for the large amount of people never
pay and we came in and we said look we
have you know authentic people because
we know who these people actually are
and we have a great set of advertisers
and these are ads which are not annoying
to the people who use you every day and
so it's kind of this play factor which
worked really well and you know again it
is only things where after the six to
eight months it really took off and and
I think you know at the time it and it
still is like really a market leader so
but but on day one when you guys
launched it wasn't like hey it was
terrible it's like four months I think
we didn't make any money at all uh and
at the time we were wondering is this
ever going to be a thing so that's I
think one of the lessons from Facebook
where these things never work on day one
you know you get the big press launch
you you know you get the big unknown
you're literally Facebook you called
anybody and they write about it yeah you
can get any partner but they never work
I know because you never seen it action
you don't know how the machine learnings
gonna work or all the zillion bucks you
hit and you got to make it matter and I
think that's out of the lesson I learned
from Facebook which is you have to grind
it out you you know and it's a little
things up one story I always keep
thinking about is in every earnings call
that Facebook good how or they would
always ask like what really you know
draw revenue and these analyst would
always be looking for an answer of what
we launched project X or product X and
that made all this money but the answer
is never really that the real answer is
more like well we have
like 2,500 different machine learning
model changes which each added like 0.1%
and they all compounded but that's
really hard to go explained and I think
that's kind of where like the hard work
is never really in these flashy launches
it's like looking at the data launching
something and building the cultural
machinery where it's ok to fail ok to
kind of explain a trade and doing it
again and again and again I think that's
one of the best things I learned from
Facebook in that era yeah
Alex Schultz when I first got there I I
can tell the story now because he would
probably laugh at me all the stories no
I'm hoping like yeah I hope they all
listen and they in the I'm what were you
in before the podcast so Alex sent me an
email I joined I was taking over as a
product manager of the growth team for
Facebook pages and Alex is I'm kind of
one of three people who kind of really
runs the grow team at Facebook and so to
most people in the growth of
organization he was you know this guy up
on on this thing but I was going with
yeah and you said it not me
haha and I didn't know who he was right
and so I guess he had sent an email and
I just missed the email and so my boss
at the time walks over and he goes hey
did Alex Schultz email you and I was
like who's Alex Schultz and he's like he
check your surge like a Eva he goes you
should progress on to that one so I
responded and he was so gracious and he
said why don't you come and meet me and
I think we have like 30 minutes or
something and one of the things that he
said to me in that very first meeting
which what you're talking about kind of
grinding it out he goes look most people
don't realize but growth is just a
continuation of compounding wins right
and it was this idea of like don't go
try to find a 10% you know increase and
click throughs or any the stuff he's
like every you know 50 basis points
every hundred basis points like it
counts right and and it adds up and I
remember one time on the facebook mobile
so it was like the mobile interface is
on like really bad phone connections
date people who are using kind of like
the t9 right so they would kind of click
through we drastically increased the
page creation so kind of top of the
funnel for advertisers by simply moving
paid create page further up in the stack
so people had a click less times on the
button to get to it
like not a groundbreaking idea right
some engineer who's like hey what if we
just move it up faster or whatever well
nobody knew how much demand was there
for who wanted to create pages and you
know Indonesia in these other countries
and all sudden there was this big jump
in revenue that kind of trickled down
and I remember Alex being so excited
about it and to me it was like man I
would have never thought you know if you
said hey what's the two things that
we're gonna do this quarter or whatever
to you know get growth I would at her be
like well we should go to the people who
are using you know like the t9 mobile
devices and move the no way I was just
testing yeah I think growth you know has
a bad reputation now as a word and
sometimes maybe deservedly so but I
think good growth at the heart of it is
looking at the data and experimenting
and then letting the data tell you where
to go so I think really well run growth
teams are fantastic at trying to feel
like what is stopping a customer from
doing something for example Facebook and
I think this was before Herrera had this
famous quote of 10 trends in seven days
of seven friends in the seven days and
the idea was unless you have the certain
number of friends in the first week or
so you were probably gonna be lonely you
were probably not going to have a
fantastic experience we end up in the
Facebook social networks so they tried
really hard in the first week to make
sure that you had friends as somebody
was leaving a comment that you know that
they would somebody would see a photo or
they would tag you and I think that's
where a good growth thinking comes from
which is really looking at the numbers
trying to deeply understand what these
people want and then experimenting very
quickly and learning from the data and
they didn't make that up right I was it
wasn't like somebody was just sitting
there like I think that you should have
10 friends and seven days or whatever
was there no they looked at the data and
the data sily suggested that there was a
massive increase in retention if you had
this number of users in this many days
yeah on the surface so let's optimize
for making people hit that metric so
that then they will say it is and I
think so the interesting question you
know in kind of tying these three
companies together is I you know if it
compares a Facebook and say snap one
thing I think is very interesting and
how pet theory is I think Snap is a
counterculture reaction to Facebook in
many ways and I have this sort of phrase
I use which is
in a big comic book nerd and the DC
universe there is a bizarro universe
where everything is the exact opposite
of what it you know what
what is the grill in our so for example
in DC universe in bizarro universe Lex
Luthor is a good guy bizarro Superman is
a batter is a bad guy you know the world
is like I think a cube everything the
exact opposite and I think of snap and
Facebook at many levels and the exact
opposites of one another so for example
and I'm gonna tie this back into what
we're talking about in culture so if you
think about snap you know Facebook was
always about let's look at the data and
let's look at where where the data is
gonna lead us to answers and they were
really good at that but I think one of
the challenges that approach and I like
to think they've done a fantastic job in
recent handling this is you can
sometimes get locked into a local Maxima
Moff optimization moodle optimizing for
yes so for example it's really easy to
find yourself like optimizing yeah the
hundred different shade of green where
there might be a much better way of
helping people create content somewhere
else and I think of snap as the exact
mirror image where snap really focused
on creativity and helping people express
themselves as their higher order bit as
the thing that they really wanted people
to do where face was often led with data
and impact so one I think these are
mirror images of each other the other
way I think they're kind of different
was at the time you know Facebook was
believed in if you remember back in 2009
or 2008 when faced with it the first f8
you had caucus [ __ ] you know chief
product officer show up on stage and
talk about how Facebook should be the
story of your life you know everything
from birth all the way to your time in
school to your marriage your first baby
it's gonna be on the Facebook Timeline
snap said the exact opposite it said the
only thing which matters is this moment
right now and who you're with right now
so nothing matters so it was the exact
opposite of what Facebook was going for
oh please because always had a really
neutral voice if you remember they
famously ran a ad where they compared
them to the bunch of chairs because they
were like we are a platform you know we
are here to help you make the world more
open
connected where snap is always believed
in having in an irreverent goofy voice
so I think in many ways they were the
exact opposites of one another which I
think sometimes that snap to find
product answers which or which a lot of
other people that are struggling I'll
give you an example so you know no face
filters and filters are you know
everyone has it every single platform
has it but when snap first build lenses
it was pretty unique you know I think
they had bought a company but it was
really the first company to kind of do
that scale seems look look sorry I think
was that yes you know I think they were
based off that you create if I remember
yeah and the question you know so I left
Facebook and I believe like in 2015 or
early 2016 to go work at snap where I
had a bunch of revenue and add products
and one of these I wanted to go there
was I wouldn't understand like why does
this company know why does this company
operate differently because we open the
app it was really app and they were
doing something different they operate
differently than every other tech
company in the Bay Area and so one way
to kind of think about this is let's
look at why do lens just work in the
easy pity and so to say well they just
help you express yourself you know and
you know it's fun it's viewed it's goofy
but if you unpack that there are many
reasons why blenders were number one and
this I think a lot of people would
assume this it's only to your close
friends and family and it disappears
after 24 hours so the downside of me
posting something embarrassing and it's
staying forever a future job prospect or
future spouse finding it or negligible
right or when I run for president you
know getting embarrassed by that are low
so one you're more open to just sharing
yourself that's one second you know like
we're doing this you know interview
right now you follow me on Twitter if I
go on Twitter right now and post a
selfie like that's mine she was posing
selfie
if I push 20 selfies on Twitter in the
next few minutes but it breaks the
etiquette that maybe how on the internet
and but you really want to put surface
and what's NAB did lenses is have you
ever been to a wedding whatever photo
booth any of these big Glaus in the
goofy glasses a lens are the digital
version of that so they give you a
social license
to post a selfie because now you're like
this part of the product and you have
these raw materials to be creative and
to be fun so what so you just are
posting a selfie
you are like doing creating a character
you're telling a story which means we do
our number three which is before lenses
and stories you could not tell a story
linearly so I'm right screen plays and
novels on the side I'm terrible at it
and and so there's this team called the
Joseph Campbell's hero's journey where
every story kind of goes to particular
you know hero wakes up he's happy he
gets a challenge he sets off on a
journey you know he accomplished his
mission and so it's kind of like you
know think of Laura things every story
follows his art with stories for the in
snap for the very first time you could
tell your own story you could say I woke
up in the morning I did this thing oh my
gosh Sanders and then I went to bed you
could not do this on feed because in
feed everything is reverse chronological
and finally and most importantly I think
stories didn't have numbers on the
screen so you had nothing which I think
let people judge you or for you to judge
yourself so for example even me
when I tweet and there's zero reactions
you know I'm you know I'm a big boy I
shouldn't need it affirmation I feel did
I say something wrong
yeah like a a and but with stories
nobody knows whether you have zero fans
or millions of them which lets you to be
more open now snap was able to combine I
think all of these and this is my own
deconstruction of why these work all of
these together and build a fantastic
product now there is no way you can
optimize your way do this you know it
requires some thinking outside the box
or a kind of original thought yeah and I
think you can optimize way to this I
think snap was very very good at those
things where they were able to make
intuitively form perform these products
which really worked for a set of people
often like young people in the way which
I think was hard for the Silicon Valley
to compete in oh of course like now I
think with Instagram and with dick
targeting a lot of other folks have
found their own ways of doing this by
the time it was like very different yeah
you want to know an interesting fact
that I found out earlier this week the
entrepreneur I believe this is correct
this is what I read online which now we
have to question whether it's real or
not because I read it online but I think
it's wrong
the entrepreneur who sold look sorry to
snap created a second company has
something to do with like more like AI
but still around content creation and
just sold that to snap as well for like
a hundred fifty million bucks Wow
so two for two same entrepreneur
somewhere in Europe I think and both
kind of creative products but out of the
box
oh yeah the creation tools so one thing
I video impressed me about that theme is
you know I really had no exposure to
Ukraine before that it's how amazing a
lot of like you know engineers there are
I suppose that Facebook do when I was if
it's you doing with this we bought this
company called library and killed it it
kill it yeah you know video yeah I had
management basically yeah and they had
some fantastic talent and I know and
they were based out of Cluj if you
remember which honestly was not a CD I
really knew a lot about before but I
would just amazed at the talent they had
and I think only now are you seeing like
with the focus on remote work
distributed teams the rising costs in
like San Francisco and New York you
think much more tech companies leverage
that but one of these I think Facebook
and snap it I had at the curve and then
it's finding these pockets of talent in
parts of what other people who hadn't
looking for like nobody was going out
and identifying a company like Cluj
right yeah and they were really good at
spotting the talent well I think live
rail again people will correct me if I'm
wrong but I'm pretty sure live rail was
the first profitable company that
Facebook ever bought and and if I
remember correctly like there was a
hiccup in the acquisition because they
were like well how do we value this
thing because they're so used to buying
products that had either no revenue or
they were burning you know venture money
and live real came along I was like no
like we actually make money like forever
that is true I think Facebook at the
time I think the big acquisition there
done was I think they've done Instagram
they were about to do whatsapp yeah
they're more than 14 my second day at
Facebook they announced what's that for
18 billion dollars I never been like
whoa yeah like this is big well that's
another example of something that you
learn from Facebook where Facebook is
very good at not letting ego or not
invented here syndrome get in the way so
a lot of other companies would have
looked at something like a whatsapp and
said look we are our own team we have
really smart people here
we should just go compete with me in
fact you'd been competing for many many
years but mark looked at that and was
like look either if we want to make the
world more open and connected that's the
mission what's up at the time had you
know close to it also on the path to
getting to a billion users you know it
was clear they want to get that order
than the number but it was good I
wouldn't get there for sure and if we
believe in having impact this is the
most impactful thing to do and if that's
word say like 10 percent or so off my
market cap it seems like a fair
trade-off so there's so much in there
which I think a lot of other CEOs would
not do you know having being able to set
aside your ego and saying I know we
competed hard with these guys but you
know you know I think you know I should
look past that and bring them in you
know focusing on impact I think mark has
done that time and time again he did
that whatsapp he was doing with the
original Instagram acquisition and also
later for example building stories into
Instagram which is very controversial I
think mark has been very good at
reasoning from first principles and
focusing on impact in a way taking a lot
of other fine people find hard yeah my
my favorite part of the whatsapp
acquisition is a yawn head applied for a
job at Facebook I can say gotten turned
down which people know but a lot of
people don't remember the part of the
story where he took the acquisition
papers and he actually signed them by
going to be what I think it was the what
where he used to pick up the welfare
checks with his family in Silicon Valley
I forget which town and he literally
there's a photo of him he's got the
papers pressed up against the door and
he's signing it right on the front door
of the building and it's just it's cool
to see how meaningful stuff like that is
to people but I think also it's a
testament to mark an executive team that
look that's somebody who's pretty
missionary driven right they're not just
building a company to build a company to
make money or anything like that to get
them to kind of see a vision with
Facebook etc and to pull off an
acquisition like that's very rare so two
things that one is the on story super
interesting so there is a cliche about
who a Silicon Valley founder is you know
you're below 30 you're wearing a hoodie
you were to start Stanford you know you
look a certain type
John doesn't fit any of that yawns an
immigrant came from a very humble
background
family was on food stamps growing up was
it had a stint at yahoo before was I
think close to 40 or already over 40
when he started whatsapp which in the
Silicon Valley scheme of things is like
oh pretty old yeah and and also he
didn't he wasn't a stand for any of the
Ivy League schools he'd want to like
come into college so in pretty much
every respect you know he was the
opposite of what a Silicon Valley found
her should be and then even the way he
built his company
what's up famously hadn't raised money
for many many years until Sequoia came
along this funneled themselves using the
I think the dollar your subscription
fees he had for many many years kept the
team really small really focus on
performance so I like to point at
whatsapp whenever you know people say
you know stereotype certain Silicon
Valley behaviors I had a point to what's
the opinion as being the exact opposite
we know the behaviors but second your
point on mark you know it takes is an
executive team to set aside like their
ego and be like well if you believe in
the mission this is the most impactful
thing we can do and I think they
negotiated that like on a Friday night
of this house yes right like it wasn't
like lawyers were involved right I think
the story that came out was just like
hey they had dinner together and they
said let you know we're gonna do this I
think so I think if I remember mark had
built a relationship with yarn over time
and and he said something like look if
we ever you know ever thinking of doing
something you know should give me a call
and we should think about this and one
holiday season you know they were like
well we should go up with the trigger
and how was this thing going to work and
I think the history sure is gonna work
out really well for like all parties
involved yeah absolutely
what about a twitter you yeah what is
the one that people probably today
people this podcast are probably most
using right so someone that might use
facebook some of my you snap but twitter
for sure but nobody really knows that
what's going on inside the company well
what's it a stockholder I'm really happy
your audience is using Twitter please
use more of it I couldn't say these
things when I was employed by the
company you know but I have no fiduciary
duty listen you're free you said tell us
all the secrets I'm going to so I left
snap and you know I was very fortunate
to be at Facebook and snap and I'm
trying to figure what I want to do next
and started started do some investing
which I'm doing a lot more now but I
just started doing some invest
and I'm still just goofing around like
if this was a summer by the way then you
know a bit Bitcoin which never sleeps as
you remind me so often on Twitter you
know was exploited I think it gone to
like you know it did the curve before
above $15,000 and I was out like I was
writing a solidity app I was just kind
of goofing around and I knew Jack for a
long time because I had been very active
on Twitter I have a little bit of a
following and Jack knew me and Jack had
just come back to Twitter I think the
Europe before and at the time today was
not in a great spot because they had
multiple rounds of layoffs jacket has
come back but it not been a long time
see it come back there were all these
rumors because I think you know Benioff
and Salesforce had wanted to buy the
company but the deal had fallen apart
which we now know because Ben Yaffe's
board had disagreed and vetoed it at the
last moment and now somebody reported
that recently and what I think K also
almost happened was Disney almost bought
Twitter and the deal fell apart which we
now know thanks to Bob iger's excellent
autobiography that he basically had a
change of heart
at the very last moment so then all this
was in the company had these you know
big heart questions deal with so Jack
and I I had dinner a couple of times and
Jack said look you know like you you
know you seem to have an understanding
of the product you use a lot and it
really is really hard challenges but
more than that you know we have like a
really important mission so one thing I
think connects all these founders and
definitely know jack and mark is here
extremely mission driven you I want to
know jack somewhat well over the last
few years I will tell you that anything
that Jack says in public is pretty much
the exact same thing he says in private
in fact he has very few secrets and
Twitter as a whole has very few secrets
and are also people you just have to
read between the lines of what he's
saying so Jack you know in this dinners
he would convince it here how much he
believes in the public conversation you
know and what he means by the public
condition what he believes in it and why
it's important for Twitter to serve the
public conversation and he really
convinced me like you know he was like
look you know the elections had just
happened so the country was going
through is really interesting polarizing
time obviously and you know the and
Twitter just playing a big part
world culture like order you know I
think I think the black lives matter had
just happened the year before and he's
like this is good this company is gonna
be really important we are going to such
a rough time you can come and help us
you know help us basically and I was
convinced you know at the for a while I
was a little bit queasy because I had
done two of these social media companies
before like I tell people like I mean
like at a nurse a nerdy tano's
collecting the Infinity Gauntlet of
social media companies right but I still
may need Kane or the jack and he really
won me over with his sincerity his focus
on the mission and I was like I said
okay I'm it so I said yes I think you
know like almost 60 years ago now and in
the text was like what do I do
so I had spent enough time doing tours
of duty and advertising and Twitter had
a fantastic team who were already
working eyes and didn't need any help
there and the question was well we need
help consumer product so uh you know and
Jack said look we need help you know
helping people stay in form using
Twitter
so everything from user growth to
onboarding do the home timeline or how
would tranqs how it looks all of it
search explore moments trends we need
somebody to kind of come in you know
take over the teams and help shape the
products and I said well this thing this
is obviously such an interesting
opportunity because it was so meaningful
sex I meant so that was Twitter and it's
been a fantastic few years there because
we one is I like to joke that Twitter is
the most public of public companies
because one you're obviously a public
company in the you know in the Wall
Street since the word you have an
earnings report you have investors and
you know you're on that cycle but you're
also public companies and you're serving
this public conversation and you have
some of the most interesting influential
communities and people using Twitter
every single day like Crippler Twitter
is a perfect example because I think you
know without Twitter you know the crypto
community would not be what it is you
know for sure yeah and you know
everything from a vitalic to Nawal
there's so many interesting people you
obviously on Twitter every single day so
you're such a public company and it's so
public insensate it's the only company
where the most important people the
world tells you how
you suck using your own product yeah so
you definitely get that - it was an
intense few years I always laugh when I
see some some big account tweet at Jack
always Adam and they say I wish there
was a damn edit button right and it's
always like you know I steer you know
like like some random account who they
they don't think of it's like a
technology product they use every day
and then they make some mistake and I
always want Jack to go be like well you
know thought of it before Thank You Jack
actually covered this reason interview
so I think the history behind this is
that Twitter was designed to be text
messaging you know and when you send
somebody in I'm strikes you don't think
of editing it and that's how they they
wanted to be this short easy to send
messaging that's kind of the heart and
soul of Twitter yet still is the heart
and soul of Twitter in many ways so it
it was not a functionality that was
needed so one was this historical
component second there was this concern
about for example let's say I say
something and you retweeted you point
out something I said was wrong and you
correct me then I change what I said you
know it could change the meaning of the
conversation that you've been having so
it's kind of these meaningful questions
about you know how do we sort of
preserve these conversations and maybe
stop that I think that a second one the
third one and you know was how important
it is in terms of how many people really
needed versus they can just fix a typo
later so I always laugh because I think
it whenever Jack tweets I see like a
million people be like yes jack but like
chip edit I doubt it's laughs you know
but Jack's very patient what is what is
it like having a CEO because Mark and
Evan both were a hundred percent focused
on the businesses meaning that they were
there every single day all day long etc
jack is fascinating to me because he's
got Twitter n square both that are
successful businesses that you could
look at it and well any entrepreneur
would hang their hat on just one of them
right and say look what I built he seems
to now with cash app and Bitcoin and a
lot of stuff like he has this appetite
for more right and so kind of what was
it like working with somebody who was
spending a lot of time it was obviously
paying attention to Twitter and
cared about the public conversation but
also you knew didn't have just one
single focus right he had these other
interests as well and right anytime
they're so the jack evident duck are so
different you know he's probably you
know mark being for an impact and speed
Evan big force and creativity jack is
very different I think he is obsessed
with thinking from first principles and
simplicity I like to joke with people
that twitter has no secrets you just
have to listen to Jack on any of a spot
cast it don't you listen to him or draw
again you listen to any of his things
he's basically laying out you know you
know what he thinks for what whither
should do what square should do it's all
there and one thing that really come to
appreciate about Jack is rigorous focus
on being focused on principles having
very simple principles and then building
your life your company every single
decision from those principles that's
one second is obsession with simplicity
so he's obsessed with keeping things as
simple as possible is it you know
hundred forty or 280 character tweet to
how squared works so if I help take away
like the top two things I've learned
from Jack I think those would be right
at the top um I would say tough that I
think one of Jack's you know you know I
always tell people you know and Jack's
you know is so different you know he
looks different you know I liked it more
walks to work he doesn't own a laptop I
think right oh yeah he's focused on his
iPad you know I like to you know make
fun of him for his you know his fashion
choices you know and you know and one of
things I think then you look at any like
well here's a person who's founded not
one but two 20-plus billion dollar
public companies and also in two
completely different domains so if you
need nothing about say Jack or how he
looks or what he says you're like how
does somebody do that maybe the I'm
guessing the number of people who fit
that pattern are probably really small I
think you learn is up there if yours but
not what people do it I think one of the
things that Jack does really well is he
finds great people you know and he'd
really empowers them so for example at
square you know he had Sarah for many
years he had Gokul dodge around for many
years at Twitter one things I think he's
been very good at is building what I
think it was an enduring theme so
you know it and that he is not needed in
every single decision so you have
fantastic people you have k1 running
product you have in a net Segal
you know who's you know probably my
favorite CFO of among NEC airforce and
Jack was like look I'm gonna build this
fantastic team I'm going to really trust
him so that I am NOT a bottleneck in any
single addition now of course when
something needs the seal away and Jack's
gonna weigh in but he really trusts his
team and for me you know that was so
liberating because you you know you know
in the first thing I was like whoa I'm
kind of running this you know meaningful
part of Twitter in this very you know
with something which by the way everyone
in tech has an opinion of arms and if
definitely one Crippler has an opinion
on but also yeah it's kind of cool
because you know jack missive you know
you're you're in charge you know you
should feel free to go do what you think
is right and that's very liberating I
think for a lot of people you don't get
a lot of that freedom and I think that's
kind of the key to how he's able to run
all these companies um what Square and
Twitter but also be also be looking
further out right he's looking further
out at you know Bitcoin and both
Foursquare and for Twitter video uh you
know and also like different countries
so I think if I think the lesson from
Jack is principles simplicity and get
great people and you go trust them yeah
you mentioned 140 characters to tid I
was in the anti character camp and not
for anything other than like hair like
Twitter and like don't screw it up right
just like for no other reason just like
it works pretty good and like why
changes right if not I gotta say though
in hindsight probably one of the best
moves that could happen I need was so
exponentially better experiences so I
remember so I can take no credit for
that because that beam was already
working on it way before I showed up
and they were fantastic smarter people
when I was having dinners with Jack
about joining Twitter he said look I'm
gonna share something with you we're
gonna gonna double the character and I
was like whoa you know because hundred
forty characters is the heart and soul
of Twitter uh and I seems a big deal and
I remember telling him Jack well
regardless of what happens right I think
it's a fantastic book number one if it
doesn't work you can always revert it
back
right but number two and I will tell you
why they did it but number two I think
it was a big symbolic move that nothing
is sacred uh that you and Jack you know
as a new kind of coming back as CEO was
like nothing is sacred we should look at
any sacred cow examine everything first
from first principles to well I think
that's why I was against it was cuz it
in my mind it was sacred right like
which which is a great kind of contrast
to even better for them to look at it
change it so the questions like why
change it right and so what Twitter was
finding was in this out yet I'll start
with Japan so what something exactly not
a lot of people know is Twitter's
hugeinjapan arm in fact for reasons
which I think kind of exactly the
opposite of why Facebook has you know
not been duly huge because you know in
Japan twitter has all these amazing
communities where you know be it manga
or be it fall in pop culture through is
kind of found this great product market
fit for jumpin for many many years
and the Japanese language and our
non-experts I could be getting the
details wrong is much more dense from an
information content than the English
language so with hundred forty
characters in Japanese you are able to
communicate a lot more then you're able
to do with hundred forty characters in
English this because the density of the
characters involved and there was this
uh I think the engineer or data
scientist who saw that and he was like
huh this is interesting so what if we
brought that exact same behavior on to
English Twitter so they did the math
they were like what is the length of you
know the Japanese actual length because
I'm hard for a guy to be able to talk to
more information what is the actual
length it's in English it came to two
hundred seventy nine which really very
well they were like you know two and
some nine characters in English kind of
matches hundred forty characters in
Japanese and we were like huh and so
that was one data point the other data
point was big Twitter graph the amount
of tweets with our characters and you
saw this curve where you know you saw a
very pretty normal distribution but
there's this huge spike at hundred
thirty nine 140 missing people right at
the limit and they were cut off we're in
Japan
you saw much
other curve right and they were like how
maybe people want to see more but
they're stuck no there's this question
of like but that's that's the magic of
Twitter you don't want people to kind of
drone on and on you have like a blog
it's not a medium medium job change go
to our medium on but in Twitter's were
meant for translations but what if you
could have both right and and we almost
had Japan as an evidence point of you
could have short succinct the creativity
the magic you know the sort of the the
creative choices you have to make to be
funny or funny or engagement Twitter but
also get people to say more and so well
207 caricature seems like a bizarre
number to go pig and you know the team
decided let's make it to 80 they
launched said and this was I would say a
very scary launch because uh most tech
companies when they launch something you
can you know you can a be tested in a
small audience you can test it out but
this is you can't test how a large
community is going to react to such a
change so Twitter was like okay we're
gonna really go in for this and this is
I think a lot Raj blood not Fred goes to
Jack because Jack had just come back a
CEO he had been there for a year and he
was like you know what I believe in this
I'm gonna go for it and we're gonna
question the most sacred of sacred cows
uh and I would if you remember this like
that was not a popular opinion right it
was not you know it's interesting when
you work at Twitter you have to pretty
quickly grow thick skin because everyone
are using the product is gonna tell you
holder on your idea and and the sue but
we launched it and the funny part is and
I think there's a great post about they
did a yearly after launch the graph
matched exactly what where it was going
to be it turns out that you know one was
he didn't change the magic you know
people are using Twitter more engaging
more but it that sort of spike where
people are stopping at hard and forty
characters smooths and smooths out and
people be able to communicate more so it
was kind of this you know I I really
like that because once the bold Asian
for Jack to make but also a data-driven
one you had his power so I love this
story but I would like for a couple of
weeks it was not fun all right
the million dollar question for Twitter
before we move on oh God everyone wants
to know how they get verified and for
for quite a while
you were the you're the victim of
whenever that question was asked of as
an
executive you were you're the guy doing
verifications well what's going on there
so first off that that part is not true
I never worked on verifications there
Adam Bane who used to be CEO of Twitter
when he left played this joke where in
his bio he pointed people to me and he
said serums of chief verification
officer and they should come to me and I
swear like every single day I got I'm
sure even just mentioning this is gonna
get me more emails now I would get like
dozens of emails from all sort of like
nice people well-intentioned people to
some really bizarre ones I got all sort
of emails and tweets I did not work on a
verification and so I will you know what
I'm gonna first time I'm gonna copy an
answer jack gave Jack was asked this
last week and he said k1 Bev poor is the
current head of product at Twitter he
said just go at tweet him he's at ka ybz
he's got you you know you know it just
tweeted him and he's gonna get you
better fight so he's not he's gonna hate
me for this at ka Y Z breezy VZ ya get
that right saying you know you want you
want to make sure it he doesn't see that
he can't verify every single every
single person a seasoned reset him he's
gonna be fine and if he do if he doesn't
see you at first just beat him a few
more times just to make it make sure
make sure yeah maybe I can give your
audience's phone number did you this is
my favorite joke in all of Silicon
Valley of all the inside jokes I'm aware
of this is my favorite one because
everyone wants to know how they get
verified on Twitter the two funny
stories think one is I should get I I
got a lot of interesting people reach
out to me I like it like serious people
as well as like for example once I get a
cold email and I'm just gonna Sony
entropy but like I got like post Malone
like say me a cold email about
gratification that was like I was not
heard of him you know but then he
followed me on Twitter to you so that
was very interesting but I also got
something really weird I had his post
Malone started an email is he's like yo
Dawg or is it more of like a hello hello
I would like a verification he had a
friend I think who needed ready fine
okay so not him not him
he was very fine he has like a huge
following he [ __ ] they're like you know
I have a friend who needs help it's post
and it's like Hosty I don't like
yeah I'm pretty sure to fail until I saw
his I couldn't just followed me yeah and
I didn't ask somebody else who knew them
and they're like a tactic legit I was
like okay then I was able to kind of get
him point him to some people the other
that means that Shriram knows who does
the verification the other I think
something you get some scary people like
you know I once God what I just kind of
roughly say somebody high in the armed
forces of a country which is not
friendly to the United States send me an
email saying their boss who was a
British senior figure had just created
Twitter account and they wanted to get
verified and when it didn't reply they
kind of send me more and more aggressive
emails and I had a sinner Twitter
security because I was like I I don't
know like this is like this real this
person has some real resources I don't
want to piss them off so and yeah
capable of some really bad things is
like really fun interesting things the
challenge is verification by the way I
think this is where like blue sky and
all these effort is really interesting
is verification is many things in once
so one is I think it is and this is not
done talking my Twitter here I think is
true for any platform like Instagram
Facebook tick-tock when you verify
someone you give in a blue check or the
green check it means one you are who you
say you are so you are actually an
authenticity authenticity second it's
also some form of social capital so
where it means it you're somehow
meaningful or your code important you're
important quite important and these
things get conflated and by the way I
think I have a theory which the social
capital and social currency is one of
the best ways to both understand social
media and to kind of have to compete
with them but in this example so you can
often have somebody who we think I was a
really bad person you know it's coming
at a crime or is it an organism is like
any reason people insist edible but they
have a lot of people impersonating them
on say Instagram or tik-tok or Twitter
and they need to verify them because
they are actually who they say they are
and these things get very up conflated
you also all these interesting questions
like for example let's say somebody is
running for office edom and you know
they get verified because you want to
make sure you know who the actual
candidates are but then after a while
you know they maybe lose and they go
back to being normal
and do you unmeritorious keep them in
sir there are all these interesting
questions so I have a lot of sympathy
for there are some really smart folks
working on all of these platforms it's a
very very hard problem which is why I by
the way so I really like blue sky
because I think they're often our native
approach ok explain so for context blue
sky is this new effort from Jack and
Twitter to basically build a
decentralized version of Twitter and my
you know the mental picture like to
paint people is think of Gmail today you
open up Gmail you open up my browser you
see a list of emails some algorithm has
sorted the spam away stuck it in a spam
folder some algorithms try to figure out
like what is social what is promotion
sawdust in the inboxes there's a
fantastic UI experience and at the
bottom of it there is some SMTP
happening and some IMAP happening maybe
when these mail servers talk to each
other at the MX protocol but you don't
really know it because you're so
abstract away and one my mental model
for this is it's a Jack basically
announced on Twitter a few weeks ago
that he and Twitter are going to sponsor
something called blue sky which is an
effort to build an open-source
decentralized social network protocol
from the ground up which Twitter's going
then going to support its very early
stages you know they I think right now
they're busy looking for somebody to
come in and run it I think it's you know
it's very likely it's gonna have strong
ties to crypto for all the obvious
reasons and my Alex was in the Gmail
example think you know you know have
Gmail but you ever had SMTP you know had
alternative client right and that's what
social media is today when you have
Facebook you have a stack you have the
UI of like how does these things look
how do I post things you have this
incredibly complicated ranking algorithm
which maybe you are familiar with like
one of the most sophisticated piece of
software ever built by mankind you have
all sorts of policies you have policies
on moderation what kind of content is
allowed to stay up or not alert stay up
your policies on verification all right
so you basically get this in a box if
there's no way you can tell Facebook
okay I want all of this but I want to
plug in my own ranking algorithm you can
do this on email like you can write a
client right now and
do your own email hosting and be like
I'm gonna pick my own spam email you
don't need Gmail you can't do it on
Facebook you can't do an Twitter and one
of things is really exciting for me is
is it what if we could now using my
analogies pull it out SMTP and email and
then a lot of people can innovate on top
of it
for example like you know you want you
you don't like how Twitter is verifying
people build your own verification
policy the the crypto community could
say we're only gonna verify people with
you know some proof of stake or proof of
work or we could have pumped Twitter
where only people who pump likes it will
get verified and no one else so you
gotta come kiss the ring
so you can imagine sort of this you know
and you can imagine for algorithms so if
you don't like how any social media
platform is prioritizing who gets amp
reach who what gets prioritized you want
to pick something like for example you
say I don't want algorithms which only
prioritize things which get liked or
retweeted I want an algorithm which
prioritize thinks is the most
information things are the most helpful
content and your way to figure this out
you could build that out but I mean even
plugged it in so you I think can really
open up a wave of innovation and just
people building on top of social media
in a way which hasn't happened for now
there's a long way to go right there are
all these unexplored questions around
how does you know hold this work you
know how other platforms support it how
will like cryptocurrency plugin is super
it is what I'm really excited for this
yeah and to me we've seen this in crypto
where people have to they want to get to
a decentralized end state and so you can
just start out trying to be
decentralized or you can start out
centralized and decentralized over time
I don't know if there's a like an
agreement yet on every single way to do
this what's the best one we know with
Bitcoin obviously just by decentralized
from day one but one person was the
first right and then it kind of
decentralized very quickly and I think
Twitter exploring this the thing that I
appreciate about Jackie he just
announced with Square they released the
Lightning Network development kit light
with blue sky it's tools right it's look
I don't want to be the guy in the
position of making all the decisions I
actually think that there's many
different answers for many different
people like here's a bunch of tools do
what you want to do right and which i
think is pretty powerful I think you can
sort of constructive
from Jack's first principles in some way
so Jack police a couple of things right
he believes that on the internet
everything's gonna live forever in a
blockchain and to that relevance
algorithms are what really matters and
someday I think I don't think people
often paid deeper into what he says and
he says but I think you can sort of
construct everything he has done from
just those two sentences so for example
if everything's gonna look farther on
the Internet
ah it doesn't really matter as much what
gets taken down or what stays up what
really matters is what gets reached and
what gets amplification so for example
like you know if we do this podcast and
no one listens to it does it really
matter if YouTube puts it up takes it
down or Spotify puts it up it takes it
down it doesn't matter to us but what
really matters is like it's 45 features
it or Apple is gonna feature it somehow
or their ranking of product that really
matters more so Jack really believes in
this and I think you know one of things
he's talked about is like he some day he
wants to get her to just be a set of
relevance algorithms working on this
corpus of content so then you know for
example if you disagree with you know
some moderation policy or who's getting
verified it's all there you can build
your own implementation and Twitter
could maybe have an alternative
implementation of that would you feel to
go do your own thing so that's one
things I'd really like to put Jack where
every one of those decisions or
returning the companies and you can sort
of build on top of his principles and
really kind of layer them on and they
all intellectually consistent which i
think is you plating this when you're a
company you know you it gives you a
framework of what is important how are
you supposed to work how do you make
prioritizes which is often really hard
so that's kind of a one of my key
lessons from Jack yeah you write a lot
and oddly uh narrow but it's very good
where can people read the writing first
ah well thank you so I think there are
two places where I'm very active one is
on Twitter itself I'm at Shriram KSR IRA
SR IRA MK at there are a Twitter and the
other is on my own site where I have a
blog and the newsletter at Shriram
kake.com where I trying to kind of
collect some of the things I've been
writing every once in awhile so you've
written on a variety of things
everything from I
but no but it's great because is
everything from like super operational
things like how do you how are you
successful as an executive when you join
a company in the first 30 days right
like that's really actionable to this
idea that I want to explore a little bit
of like organizations being systems
right and kind of Apollo and all the
stuff so you talk a little bit of it
like how you think about yeah
organizations as systems and like where
does that really come sue so by the way
my motivation for writing is very simple
it's very selfish I think I really think
writing online is a superpower I highly
encourage everyone to do it because it's
the best way to put up a portfolio of
who you are and how you think to the
world and and you know it has opened so
many doors for me I've met so many great
people both for work and not work I
highly highly recommend everyone doing
it for example you had a previous guest
David peddle on here yeah I I met him
through his writing I loved what he was
writing and I met him and you know he's
one of the smartest people I've met
purely from his just from his writing
alone so I think it's a real superpower
and I had I would say to ulterior
motives for writing you know one was I
love meeting interesting people and we
write something you when you write
something and it's hopefully good
interesting people seek you out because
you find they're often trying to find
great things also so I offer you know
it's a good way to be like here's the
bat-signal when you write on a topic you
often get the best people in the world
reaching out to you so I talk to example
when I start writing on like companies
and you know collecting some of the
emails from these companies I got so
many interesting people just email me
and talked to me about it so it's a
great you know it's kind of like having
a homing beacon where you get really
smart people to come to you interview
having to go to them so that's one and
the second thing honestly it's for
myself because you know a lot of these
things I'm writing on something where I
had no idea what I was doing and kind of
through painful trial and error I
learned something or a period of time
and I'd kind of help me work through my
thoughts and then after some time I can
kind of go back and refer to it so for
example I have this post which is
referred to on the first 30 days in the
executive so
and when I mean I kind of took on sort
of these more and more meaningful roles
I really struggle with like how do I do
this job you know and look a lot a lot
of people I think struggle with the
impostor syndrome and I was one of them
I was like I'm too young I haven't done
this before why should I be running you
know why should be telling like you know
200 people what to do and I built a
playbook over time you know asking other
people so for example you know I think a
lot of people hit this thing where they
get a new job you know either you join a
new company in a senior role or you get
a promotion where you're now an executed
running a really large organization or
maybe you just taken on a different role
and you were say a general counsel and
you're now like a CEO or a CFO going to
CEO I think all these are new jobs and
you it's really hard to figure out what
you should do because the people don't
know you they don't trust you it's a new
job so you don't know what you're doing
you don't have all the answers at your
fingertips yet but we will only look to
you for the answers and by the way the
clock is running because unless you show
impact and results they're gonna be like
somebody's just being paid a lot of
money but like why is he or she even
here so and I struggled a lot myself so
I built this playbook
where and by the way Andrew Bosworth you
know bars at Facebook is you know one of
the folks who really had me with this
was first was unfortunate is you follow
this number one is you go meet everyone
that you literally meet any every single
you do nothing else but just meeting
people all day you don't know active
decisions you are you you take part of
like really no active work he's me
differently every peer every you know
mid-level manager every skip level to
board everyone you can think of in every
meeting you do the same thing you know
one if you're what they're working on
but you ask them two questions right at
the very end you ask them what are the
sort of the few things that you want to
see improved in this art and who are
other two smart people I should go talk
to and very quickly we just within two
three weeks you're gonna build a map
you're gonna build a map up these are
repeating themes that show up do is
you're gonna figure out like who all the
smart people that who act as information
source and you should keep an eye on so
you get gonna kind of act as this this
like huge axillary education path in a
very short period of time
so that step a I think step B is to just
communicate all the time so when you're
new I have this place called like you
you have to be elected elected not
selected when you get a new job I think
an often
the execs you know who fail think that
they know how power but you don't write
you have hundreds of people thousands of
people you know who now have to believe
that they are in the best job possible
for them that you're someone worth
listening to and you might be but you
haven't proven it to them yet they don't
know you they you mean you may have just
seen a press release on you or you they
might have seen you as a different
organization but not running this so
what do you do so and I think you have
to communicate you have to talk about
who you are what you're doing all the
time so they hear from you they get to
know you and this can be as simple as
like an email a week with like here are
my top priorities in terms of who am i
meeting right so they could know who you
are as a person a little bit more
because as an executor you often like
have so many people and they don't get
to face that and they're gonna make snap
judgments or if your based on seeing in
the hallway or some offhand comment so
the more you can talk to them and hear
from you directly I think it's super
powerful when they're getting know you
that second third I think is you have a
very limited time window to make changes
so I would tell you about a month and I
think any team when you come in you're
gonna find out that there are certain
things are not working you know either
organizational structures or often just
people and it's not that fault you know
it could be that they were in the wrong
role or you know or it's some reason
it's not working out now the team is
going to look to you to make those
changes very quickly because I and I've
seen is a reorganization you know
there's always some like well-known
thing which is going wrong and the teams
will almost judge you be test it's a
test off like can you actually fix it
for us quickly because the other person
the predecessor you know he or she could
not so you have a limited window to do
the obvious thing and I think you know
and I think so and finally and I think
this is super important they have to see
you roll up your sleeves and be in
action so uh Rahm Emanuel used to be
mayor of Chicago and then in a work of
the Obama decision had a great quote
which is never waste a good crisis and I
believe that in the first two months if
there is some way for you to dig into
the details and not something super
abstract like you know here's a strategy
for next five years not that that's not
important but it's often more abstract
going to take more time something as
simple as hey you know what you know
this you know customer
you want to lose this customer right or
this product launch is not going well
and for you to figure out how to add
value right um and roll PC and this is
very important because adding value is
very different like sometimes you
snooping in can be the worst thing
because you don't know anything you
don't know you but for you to be useful
and following the see you in action
and for the girl this presents Kathy not
so bad you know they're up rolling their
sleeves and they're doing something so I
was very lucky at like you know my first
up you know a couple of months we had
this big product launch that we had to
go through you know mostly morally built
it but it kind of the big end stages of
it so I got a chance to be like okay
this is great because now I get to meet
everyone they get to see me in action I
get to learn a lot and they get kind of
an axial dated version of knowing what
it is to work with me and I think that
goes a long way in helping you build
credibility so now I kind of built this
playbook or a bead of time most of the
trial never you know and I wrote this
just as a reference to myself and you'll
be amazed how often like people that
come to me they're oh I just cuz I love
this and this is what I've learned and
now I learned something from them so
that's one no nomination systems one
things you know I being in facebook snap
and Twitter is you know is there are
many ways to do the same thing build the
same product in fact I joke that I've
been in this exact same position in
three different companies and you get to
really see how different teams and
organizations structured things very
differently
so just for honestly for my own
education I started really diving into
this what makes a good organization and
you have so much literature on this
right like you know I'm sure they're
like a zillion Harvard Business School
case studies can go to a billion
business books but for me I think I look
at a couple of places right I looked at
what are some of the most quickest most
impactful projects that I've ever been
done you know and it turns out like when
I'm sending someone to the moon pranks
you know right at the top either and and
and also where can I really understand
not just by reading books how the
insides of great organizations were
right and that's when I actually started
collecting my memos because I found like
that's actually a great way is when you
kind of look at how they communicate on
the inside you understand how they work
and then you can build a sort of a
system or a playbook so for example you
know when you look at like Muller and
what they did with Apollo you know there
are some very basic things it got very
right
for example things which sound very
obvious but small peeps everyone world
knows what the goal is
everyone knows what the steps to the
goal are there is super open
communication which was not a given
super crisp sort of like intermediate
steps and metrics they need to go ahead
because you can just someone since then
summer the moon you need to have
launched something the space and have it
come back quickly and yet all these
other things you need to go where if I
and this was really brain-dead but
exactly turns it be really hard and most
people don't even get it right and I
just started collecting these examples
because for me you know one thing cells
trying to figure out a Twitter is how do
I make you know my you know part of her
better functioning well Ron delivering
fantastic product experiences and I was
like how do we go learn this so I'm just
looking well let's look at all the
classes let's look at some of the best
products that ever been ever been but so
that's gonna work start started my
curiosity where did that curiosity
converge with memos right so we're
talking before that I think you and I
both like these memos which are usually
a little bit longer kind of writings
from well-known figures I've taken more
of a liking to what I call financial
memos so these are Wall Street investors
who write quarterly or annually the you
know more Buffett annual letters
probably most famous of the that type
you have spent more time reading and
really liking what I'll call like the
operator memos right so this is Mark
Zuckerberg this is Katzenberg you know
all these folks who are writing where
did that fascination or curiosity come
from honestly out of purely selfish
motivation where you know when I for
example joined Twitter I was like I
don't know how to do this job you know I
never done an organization of this size
before this complexity before in such a
public way and I and how do you mean
communicate right like how do you write
a fantastic strategy dog but it would
memos overload which is an email or in a
just a dog you know how did a great
strategy talk how do you send an email
to the team which motivates them when
times are hard and I just started
collecting examples one things you
quickly realize and I think even instead
of these companies is the inside of
these large tech companies are chaotic
very personality driven
and whenever some press pieces like oh
this company has explicitly I'm like are
you kidding me and get like five people
to meet together in the same room at the
same time and and often I think it's
really hard to form a accurate
impression of what is happening on the
inside from just reading press releases
or even reading books after the fact you
just don't get the inside but that is
one way to figure out what is actually
happening inside to go read the actual
words these people have written the
executives you know the CEOs the
founders you know the presidents and
these are often really hard to find you
know one because they on the inside
they're often protected they're not not
often made public so over the years in a
winner one of these would pop up I just
kind of stuck him in a little Dropbox
water so what it for example and you
were often pop in a few ways like you
know one somebody's a historical I have
a lot of historical ones I have one from
like annex White House chief of staff I
have one from like you know
viewpoint about it I was some of the
historic ones are now made their way in
the public domain
a lot of them are through leaks so for
example when the Sony leak happened I
think the press relooked at the
salacious details you know I looked at
like how does SUNY run as a company you
know what are all the great smart
executives writing in how do they
motivate their team how are they writing
an all-hands memo how are they writing
delivering bad news I kind of looked at
that just you could learn from that's to
our third it comes from press leaks for
example you know you know Facebook
recently had a bunch of emails which by
the I'm active members is in there um
released by the UK government and and
again the pressor thing is gonna focus
on you know like certainly Shriram said
what yeah I actually turned so that I
actually came out looking pretty good so
I was I did have a moment of no I was
like you know did I say something really
embarrassing so I actually I came out
looking pretty good but you know but I
looked at like okay what all these folks
were I really expected what did they
doing so and they're like oh the years I
just kind of collected them and about
four or five months ago I put it up on
my side it's a free rom-com slash memos
and it was amazing so one is I think the
memo is kind of it's a great teaching
tool to help you understand how
different leaders handle situations so
couple of my favorite ones one is
let's use one from Facebook Mark
Zuckerberg is one of the most aesthetic
thinkers you will ever meet but hands
hands down hands down yeah you know and
you know and you better be in a meeting
with them you're like you just blown
away by the sheer force of a like and I
think you and I have been these things
so you you know how real that sentences
but and to me the intellect isn't like
oh he's a big thinker I remember there's
a meeting once and I won't go into all
the details but basically there was a
new product that was being presented to
him that hadn't yet been rolled out and
he was having to think very
strategically about the resources that
were being used where does this fit
inside of our kind of our plans the
impact it could have you know a whole
bunch of like really big things and
literally in the middle presentation he
drilled then it was like that that
what's wrong with that and it was like
pixel level attention to detail and it
was just like holy [ __ ] like ten
thousand foot view down to your feet on
the ground back to ten thousand view all
in seconds and it was interesting yeah
humbling because you're looking to be
linked I have the same data that he has
him looking the same thing in forgive
sometimes closer to it but he's able to
see a pattern or he's able to kind of
play out a set of like chess moves into
the future of how something would play
out and he looks for that I head and
this amazing and it's even harder to
talk about this in public well you just
saying that because like Mark Zuckerberg
you work for mark or something here but
it is really true and also it's never
exposed to the public because all of its
internal Facebook which is why every
facebook employee often talks about this
but you know you don't really see in the
press except a bunch of his emails over
time I've kind of shown up in the public
domain because of you know leaks or
because of you know a requester oh yeah
because of like these babies of legal
processes so I found in a couple of
these memos which was a great you know
now I have an example which you know I
can showcase the world which won't get
me like sued by you know Facebook legal
of like hallmark right so one of my
favorite ones is on the side which is
Mark about a couple of years ago he
makes a case for why Facebook should buy
unity right and it is like a 7 - it's
like almost get 7 to 8 page memo now you
should think about if you can think of
like a lot of companies by this
condition up later of course the deal
that will happen but a lot of
connections this have been like about
the math the numbers the valuations and
other
I've been doing it for Marc as you know
CEO of like a phone had been our company
but Marc is a memo himself and he later
this strategic rationale about how he
sees Facebook changing how he sees the
face world changing and adopting gaming
more and he says look we are a
communication platform you're all board
or you know mid-level open and connected
but essentially we always run on someone
else's platform we run on Apple we're on
Google but for long term for us to be
you know not at sort of you know yet the
women fancy of someone else we need to
own our own platform and unique kind of
makes this case where we are an AR and
unity as a part of it and then he says
well if we do unity what's it gonna mean
how do we get like you know different
companies to work with us when they stop
working with us and this just like there
are so many things going on in here one
is a 10,000 foot level he's thinking
about how the world is gonna change and
how technology's gonna change second
he's thinking about Facebook strategic
position in that world and how you know
what it needs to do to compete to stay
ahead of things third he's thinking
about if this happens what game tearing
out various situations and he's really I
remember more to say exactly why he
doesn't need to he just basically say
the word they can do it but it's a
fantastic way of writing and I look at
it whenever I need to like you know like
to write something listed teaching of
how to break down an argument and be
really thoughtful so that's one example
to look at a very different kind of
example like Jeffrey Katzenberg you know
writes this famous memo you know and
Katzenberg of course you know now works
on creepy but you know he's obviously a
Hollywood legend for his dime at like
you know Disney and DreamWorks and he
writes his great memo in the early 90s
about how the current Hollywood studio
model is broken and such an interesting
look at sort of in insider opining on
movie studios which you'd never see
because you're talking to a peer so you
won you understand the space you
understand double cab a space and you
such fantastic strategic thinking in
action
but my favorite memo and I think this is
one which not a lot of people notice
because it's not like a well-known name
is Dave Goldberg right and so Dave
Goldberg you know
whoo I think we all knew very well with
you know with shells husband he sadly
sadly passed away a few years ago he was
CEO of Searle monkey and in his there's
an email between him to Michael Lynton
who was surrounding Sony here in the US
at the time where you know I think
Michael had asked him you know help me
understand the music business and this
is an email sent from one person now the
first thing nobody else is gonna see
this error and I'm particularly if I
hadn't put him on the site like now
never gotten Sean but it's by the way
it's the CEO of Sony asking Dave
Goldberg about the music industry like
pretty crazy
he's pretty crazy and you know and he
basically breaks down you know how does
this industry work you know how who
makes money in a house of Sony pushing
itself strategically is one of the best
written emails I've seen and it blew my
mind because as to my knowledge before
the SUNY emails got hacked only one
other human being had ever ever seen
that email so I think you know what this
helps me with all these emails is in the
finance world when you're an investor
writing a letter you have a bunch of
objectives you are here to you know talk
your portfolio you're talking publicly
for sure yeah you're taught you and
you're basically saying look I'm a great
person to be a custodian of your money
in some shape or form but we need an
operator you have multiple agendas so it
you are trying to make a case to
management you're trying to make a case
often do people work for you but you
still need to make cash them you're
trying to rally the troops you're trying
to bring morale up you are trying to
help simplify a really complicated topic
with multiple different incentives there
are so many different things going on
and for me the memo is kind of act as
like kind of this educational aid where
I'm like okay these are the Great's have
really done it and you know if you know
if you have like a White House chief of
staff writing a memo to his successor
like whatever problem you are solving is
like much less important than what they
were dealing with so and how did they
deal with that so it's a fantastic
education it and so I put this up a few
months ago on the side what has blown me
away since then and this writing by
writing on insta superpower is every day
an email about it and you get some of
the most thoughtful beautiful emails and
I get people sending me new memos I get
new memos all the time and sometimes
you can say me that because your company
is like legal department is going to
either sue me sue you but sometimes you
can't ask people who just say me their
own memos or memos they know of and it
is beautiful so I've gotten to add so
many fantastic memos and just kind of
it's all this machine which keeps going
so I it's what has been one of my
favorite things to do when you put the
the light up right and people are
attracted to it it's like it really is a
magnet it is and you know ma one of my
goals is to someday maybe like interview
the people in the memos uh and think
about what is going on when you're
writing the memo right like and some of
them are still alive some of them very
active for example I have like you know
Bryan Armstrong of coinbase
you know doing a memo or how to be a
good product manager that he wrote it is
PM's
at coinbase but you know now a lot of
people say I'm like what are you
thinking or even some boy back to Zach
or go back do you know somebody at
Google or somebody historically I
wouldn't even somebody do a book on
these yeah but for now I just love it
it's a treat and I use it all the time
so another thing that I know you love is
LeBron James okay let's talk about it
where does the fascination with LeBron
come from and is he the goat the
fascination of LeBron is ah he's
absolutely the good the fasted LeBron
comes from the fact that I like to annoy
people no I'm a troll at heart I am a
troll
you know I like to annoy people and so a
few years ago like I live in San
Francisco right and San Francisco hates
LeBron because Golden State Warriors you
know with the peak of the power for many
years and LeBron was you know Darth
Vader
Waldemar told in 20 you the only one San
Francisco has been spoiled they did what
they had the via the baseball then they
went to warriors now they got the 49ers
who seem to be doing pretty good with
Colin Kaepernick era with the beauty
well and the you know there's an age
where they had like you know the Steph
Curry splash brothers kept Kaepernick
the Giants doing but it was an amazing
time for San Francisco but you know I am
always a bit of you know to use his
overused phrase a bit of a contrarian
and I know this was during the our 2016
finals if you remember the Warriors were
up 3-1
and I made a funny post on Facebook I
thought it's funny I'm like no I'm
pretty sure like LeBron and people are
gonna come back in with the series at
this time I was a fan of LeBron and I'm
fan of him few reason I'll get into but
I just kind of said that I didn't really
mean it but then you know they won in a
game five and then they famously won
Game six where Steph got ejected then he
went a Game seven
and I was like oh my gosh this could be
getting real and then Game seven happens
lebron chases down you know dolla you
know and Kyrie hits a jumper and I was
like oh my god I said my feed exploded
people are so mad at me I just like wait
I know how this thing which is no
reliable going to annoy people and I
loved it so since then it kind of
becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy where
you know where I just love to trot out
LeBron because it is annoys the heck out
of you know all of my you know friends
and peers in San Francisco I actually
usually I'm a huge fan of LeBron for a
bunch of reasons my biggest reason is I
think in any professional career it is
really easy to coast on what made you
successful at first right now what are
we your first thing was you I see a lot
of people who max out because they were
like I've become as good as I think he
can be I'm really good at this thing I'm
just gonna con you doing this thing but
I think it takes a certain other kind of
person to continuously reinvent
themselves and to always forget what the
game is and stay out of the game like I
think of you know my wife always
mentions Madonna in this context of
always reinventing herself and you
forget LeBron liberals always reinvented
himself like when he came in you know he
had no jump shot
he's kind of is like you know he relied
on his speed and athleticism
went on this personal journey where he
went to Miami was hated because of the
decision you know learnt from that and
then he kind of became this one sort of
in the public realm this lovable figure
you know working with kids and a crowd
you know kind of becoming a spokesperson
for like so many important social causes
on the court became a leader
change this game and he's gotten older
he's kind of like to figure how to play
with that he's always been reinventing
himself and staying ahead of the game
like he's like you know he's like 35 now
right and he's still one of the most
athletic people in the league that was
not a thing back like in
like 10 years ago and that can only
happen with not not so you know gifts it
only have any heart in winter so that
really inspires me so I actually am a
huge fan of a Bron but for a different
reason his dominance on the court is
undeniable right yeah I'm not gonna
change anyone's mind I always talk about
like the goat argument of like LeBron
Jordan Kobe whoever you believe going in
the conversation I'm not gonna change
your mind
that's who you believe next stuff out
but the thing that is so crazy to me
about LeBron LeBron is probably probably
the last athlete that started out in an
era where social media wasn't really a
thing yet like it was just starting and
now continues to play at the highest
levels in like this explosion of you
know basically can't walk down the
street without somebody taking a video
of you right
and so at 16 years old I think it was
he's on the front cover of Sports
Illustrated chosen one all this stuff 16
years old how many other kids you know
Sebastian Telfair I can go do all right
they were all there they were on the
covers and they all fizzled out so one
he made it right in terms of he actually
fulfilled the athletic promise but two
is you've never heard drugs in fidelity
doing something wrong you know partying
like a fantastic role model I mean look
at him you know I mean people don't
criticize him for talking about his kids
way too much but he's obviously a great
dad he's a great family but it's just a
fantastic role model well it's really
hard to be at the peak of your sport and
to have you know all the activation be
one of the most recognizable names in
like the world really it's very very
remarkable and my whole thing is just
like that level of scrutiny for now you
know what is it at 20 years right
surprised 16 to 35 36 years old to do
that and be the one of the best players
if not the best player you know in the
history of basketballs Chris it's just
it's really really hard to do that I
think that like the average person
doesn't understand those types of
pressures I don't understand type of
pressure right and I don't think is very
many people listening who understand
that but we've seen it over and over and
over again everyone cracks my Tiger
Woods Kobe Bryant me you just go down
the line right Conor McGregor recently
like all these guys they all end up
doing something stupid and some of it is
Fame goes through their heads
it's just they make a dumb decision you
know some of it's their undisciplined
whatever LeBron for 20 years has been
kind of untouchable and your biggest
Catrice is hey he made a decision on
live television donated a million
dollars to like the Boys and Girls Club
okay there could be worse things writer
he talks about his kids too much
whatever I think it's just pretty cool
to see somebody kind of thrive in that
environment
it's kind of hard hey though it is and I
think that's like anybody in like any
normal job which is to just reinvent
yourself right yeah and the game always
changes you know for some metaphorical
definition of the game I hope you stay
ahead of the curve I think it's - for
example I talked a lot of venture
capitalist I was talking to you know if
you look at some of the great venture
capitalist they've been able to have
great hits across many generations and
one of the original job was like John
doar was you know a sales VP at Intel
you know him you know help getting
Google or picking Google I don't think
being a sales VP the Intel is gonna set
you up for that so you obviously kind of
have to reinvent yourself stay ahead of
the curve and you do it over a long
period I think LeBron will do and that's
that's why he's really inspiring yeah he
really annoys everyone up my friend what
uh what are you doing now you're doing a
lot more investing in startups I'm
tweeting okay that's podcasting there's
all of that so uh ii-i've been doing a
lot of interesting so when when you have
an active day job you know you don't get
a lot of time you know and you know now
I have some free time I loved helping
young founders founders and
entrepreneurs so I've been able to do a
lot of that you know soo-bin one is
doing a lot of investing on the early
stage and it's kind of really helping
shape mostly consumer companies but lots
of young companies are we just how to
think about product and operations and
second is just to help like other even
like later stage companies with you know
it's I call it like my war stories I'm
like well I don't know what you guys
should do but like these are the
mistakes I've made so at least please
don't repeat the same mistakes so but
mostly being investing I gotta say that
out of everyone that I know or have
worked with you probably if you cut your
experience by the types of companies
the variety at which you worked at the
highest levels and also what you did
with
in those companies so products right ads
etc there's not very many people who
have kind of done that much right
there's usually like okay I do sales or
I do product yeah I'm product manager I
work on growth whatever and maybe I go
to to three companies and do that same
thing but my father told me this one
time he said there's some people who get
they work on something for ten years and
they get two years of experience five
times right right but it's the same
thing five different times and so yeah
was 10 years biscuit two years living
specialist thank you that's very kind of
you but ii mu you know i not like
blowing hot air behind it you are the
living epitome of doing that like you
know i new palm back and ads at facebook
and he always stood out because he was
one of the smartest most like you know
logical thinkers in the room and also
one of the loudest voices like literally
but he's known as smartest most logical
thinkers and you know I've kind of seen
you reinvent yourself where well you
know to Bitcoin Never Sleeps for that so
we're I think you are the living at
Potomac and across industries so yeah be
thank you but I think you're aware of me
there yeah well I think that you follow
something similar than I do of just like
it's where does your interest take you
right and it all leads back to kind of
this authenticity thing and I think a
lot of people the the joke of that like
you get have ten years bachelor two
years experience five times is those
people tend to just do what they think
they're supposed to do right so I was
like I'm supposed to go to do this and
then I'll wait two years then I go do
this and then after that I did joint
venture capital firm as a principle and
then I do this and it's like their whole
life they already have like script it
out and I've always just been like well
like what if I don't want to do that
alright like what if this other thing is
more interesting or that you know
whatever and it's like the whole I have
a master plan let me turn the tables if
you are a young person right and you are
you know for example I think the path is
yeah you get a job maybe how a b-school
degree you know you get if you get a
b-school degree then you come in you
rise up the corporate ranks or Silicon
Valley Bay which is you know you become
a founder and you start something but
you don't want to how do you know what
your path should be so how do you
somebody I actually think they look for
company so I actually think the best
thing that somebody can do and there's a
couple of kids I don't use their names
too
but there's a couple of kids that I know
that range in age between I'll say
they're probably 20 to 25 right so
they're either should be in college and
they didn't go for whatever reason or
they're just out of school and they're
all executing this very very well but
basically what I tell them when I see
them doing this is like look go find
people that need help whether they
realize it or not and be overly helpful
but don't go find that person that's at
you know the entry-level employee at
some company go and talk directly to the
CEOs of startups and go talk to the
partners at these investment firms and
they always say the same thing like oh
like that person one time whether they
once I found 23 years old right and I
say well they're gonna want to talk to
you for one it's your reason it's either
they think that you've got really unique
insights or two that you can do
something to help them right and what I
think that the people who have seen do
this really well as they rush Twitter is
a great tool you can reach out to anyone
right LinkedIn writing online like
there's all these little hacks that you
can do but very quickly like David
pearls a great example he wrote on mine
a bunch everyone started you know one
person read it was like that's
interesting another person read it and
they shared it and actually everyone
knows everyone looks like oh yeah that
did smart like it gets a certain part of
the world that most of us don't think
about all day long like that's great
I'll mention another person that this is
not a young person I don't think and so
don't get mad I've never been a man
person but Matthew ball Matthew
unbelievable so he just left Amazon
Studios I believe his new center if you
folks haven't subscribed this shirt he's
a friend I've known for years
Oh have you okay so I only like in the
last like two to three months started
like started seeing his stuff and I
don't think I've read something that
he's written that I wasn't like holy
[ __ ] this too smart right and he's just
analyzing everything from Disney plaus
to media models I call this stuff you're
sitting there you're just like I cannot
believe that this content is on the
internet for free like you can learn
anything
and so I even think that there's people
who are really good at like let me go
find information let me consume it and
like put it in my brain and then turn
around and like regurgitate it back to
somebody else right and like if you're
good at doing that and synthesizing
those you know Matthews 20 page write up
and then turning around and helping
immediacy
put it into practice like that person's
probably gonna think you're shy I have
so many thoughts on this I think first
is I think a lot of people actually make
fun of me for writing because in the
inside of a large company you know all
your pushing of power it's not obvious
why you want to tweet or why you want to
write you're like why are you wasting
this time but you know it's such a real
super power when you write because it
pays off in these nonlinear ways that
you never really understand when you're
able to help people finding great people
in so many ways so for example I a lot
of people come ask me you know I want to
get into product management and I don't
have either you know the right
background I'm in like a different role
and how do I get in do I just apply you
know Cole to this company and chances
are if you apply cause you probably not
nobody's gonna look at you though
because some resume you're gonna get
screen and B not because they aren't
they're terrible people they only have
finite amount of time and if someone has
not been doing product management you
just don't have enough time to go
through every single person now
I also need exact something which is
there's one sure way to get every head
of product or CEOs attention which is
you write a dog or a set of tweets you
talk to them about the biggest things
that company or the product should be
focusing on they're not doing right a
strategy memo or bright Mark's do
whatever it is if you could add and just
send it to them or tweet it even better
tweet it and I guarantee you to see you
the founder the head of product they
will reach out to you and they will
craft coffee
there'll be super-impressed somebody's
critically thinking about their business
yeah and I honestly did eat it in the
share it every single time and I know I
was talking to somebody who wanted to
pick in the company and he and this
person he had like no background in tech
no computer science background and it is
really challenging to break into product
manager you don't have that but he wrote
this memo this you know really hot
startups founder saw that memo and got a
minute in you know it's like product
roles so you know I that's what I think
and I'm not saying you need to do it
just because I got a job though it's
actually really way to go get a job and
have a portfolio I think it really pays
off in these nonlinear ways which are
unintuitive which is why I like I
recommend everyone write online beta
tweet my newsletter a blog it's a living
portfolio of your work and it's going to
pay off for you yeah it's why Twitter I
think it's so powerful
is because you is it's kind of like
reading somebody's conscious dream of
thoughts right it's like what does that
person thinking about today Polina
usually gives me our time she says
there's times where like we'll have a
conversation 20 minutes later she sees
me tweet something and she's like are
you some tweeting me yes right I the
same aren't the Aarthi she think yeah I
get the same thing right and it's not
always about like your relationship or
it just might be a conversation that we
had and she's like hey like tag me next
time first of all borders need to start
doing that but you know I think I think
you know there is a certain I think one
of the hardest thing one things people
find really hard about Twitter is I
think the best tweeters are in this
efficient frontier of being vulnerable
um but also not being something a lot of
carrier like Jared Diamond you know in
Oregon job which is fantastic energy of
like a civilization which is too chaotic
falls over a cliff but if you're not
changing enough you know you get still
in your diet I don't think the best
tweets are something like that where you
know if you're not vulnerable you know
if you're not open to people criticizing
you or giving you tough feedback you'll
never post anything interesting which is
why you know like so many people you
know who just post press releases or you
know or are so scripted or not
interesting people to follow um but on
the other hand you know show is to blow
up your whole career using Twitter and
you need to find what I call that edge
um at the edge is magical like now all
for example one of the best people are
found who's found that edge and there's
something in you it takes some courage
because it's such an unnatural thing to
be somewhat vulnerable and you don't
need a lot of flack for it your friends
are gonna tell you while doing this is
obviously stupid idea a lot of strand um
stages are internet definite gonna tell
you it's a bad idea
oh boy there's something magical about
putting all your ideas knowing they're
gonna be wrong but getting feedback may
be the smartest will talk to them
because when you do that when you share
these ideas um it kind of pays off if
you finally smart will come back to you
and you gravitate towards you and you
build these communities over time and
that's something magical so you attract
like-minded people yes and and you
formally seventeen which you never can
and Twitter by the way so amazing
for that Twitter is the best place to
farm meet like-minded people around
pretty much any community like for
example I recently started tweeting I
got interested in spy satellites you
don't know there there is an active sub
community of people who are on the world
amateur astronomers are I know what the
term is but they talk spy satellites so
they're tracking the spy satellites to
try to understand where their position
didn't yes in fact they only know at all
the pushing sorry because they can track
all the launches so for example there's
this guy and I actually what's the link
in my recent newsletter when you demand
President Trump posted this photo of
this Iranian yeah reacted blown up this
guy who's this Dutch professor he
doesn't have a day job connected to
satellites just using that photo and the
angle of the Sun computed which
satellite it was and it was not
previously unknown satellite and second
that it had an imaging sensor that the
US had never admitted to and he just
does it using just the footer and this
is amazing blog post you know where he
breaks the math of like trying to
analyze the sun's angle and the
trajectory of the earth it's amazing
and so yeah this weird kind of eccentric
set of people around the world will do
this and they put up these little
cameras on their porches at night which
track supplies as they pass by and
they're like well do I know this thing
do I know this thing and they share and
this is email list which I joined for a
period of time then it got very nerdy
where they shared you know this
information and it's this really it's a
very nerdy these activity which also
fascinate don't do that from your
backyard you can track pretty much any
scar spy satellite from any government
which I didn't even know but and iPhone
all these pelant or I know I know follow
all of them I know have a list of people
for all tracking spy satellites and
you're like where do you find that like
where do you find that group of people
if not on Twitter and it only happened
because I probe the street about you
know this Trump photo and then somebody
else had replied added someone else and
it kind of became a thing speaking of
satellites believer or non-believer and
aliens
um can I answer this in a different way
okay
then people ask me a question which is
what are things that have changed my
mind on okay and my top answer is always
when
until five years ago I believe that
meeting aliens was a good thing
I know meeting aliens is a terrible
thing okay it's and very early in life
do you have like one book or one moment
when you know that change your mind but
I have this which is I'm gonna butcher
this named chicken Lou who is one of the
most famous one of the most awesome
scifi writers of her time I wrote this
Chinese sci-fi novel called the
three-body problem it's not worth
reading the three-body problem yes it's
no this very famous trilogy it's
probably one of the most famous literary
works to come out of China in the last
10 years it definitely the most
well-known work of sci-fi in the last
like five 10 years and I don't wanna
spoil it but the this trilogy roughly
deals with humanity running into an
alien race uh I can be no doubt about
this balloon yeah of course so just so
you have context on the podcast this all
started because I used to ask is there's
such thing as alien pets so we just like
to think about alien like a race right
but we never think about well like are
there multi species so I like are their
pets and stuff so that kicked off the
whole aliens thing I've had 200 plus
people answer the question all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] and one of I think you are
now only the second or third guest ever
to basically pontificate about wait a
minute every single person in the human
race that has been invaded has it turned
out well like like pretty much across
the board the invader usually has a
significant sounds like that's kind of
what you're talking about
so the trilogy basis is it's called
there's a theory and it's called the
dark forest theory the dark force thing
yeah and I don't spoil it I don't give
just but the rough contours of it is
space is so vast and communication is
takes so long and you have so little
context when you're communicating then
you can't assume good intentions so for
example I'm sure I'm butchering this and
I'm sure you know your listeners I'm
going to point this out but my
interpretation of it is you know we
often sometimes think look alien races
are going to be so a wall that you know
that you know they don't harm uh they're
gonna be beyond like warfare etc I think
what the book makes a very convincing
argument for is alien races can't trust
each other because the
nature of space so the safest thing to
do is to never being spotted by another
alien race and the more despot them is
to try and destroy them and they yeah in
the book is fantastic there's a reason
why it's one of the most famous sci-fi
book what's every sometime it really put
reasons this out of why it's from a game
theory perspective it's a smartest thing
to do and so that can change my mind
where you know when I was a kid I loved
sci-fi you know I'm one of my favorite
works of all time it's called seconds
contact you know the SETI program I used
to obsess over that I don't sci-fi but
now you know I'm like you know sending
you know these probes into space which
have like basically a homing beacon on
humanity is like maybe one of the most
reckless things and I'm sure a bunch of
you listeners like oh my gosh is
somebody nerdy geeking out I just go
read the book there is a very well
thought out game theory perspective on
why is the bad thing it's called a dark
forest ball in the book is called a
three body problem three body problem
has the dark force theory the dark
forest period okay before I let you go
you get ask me one question but first
which thoughts on Bitcoin we're supposed
to talk about Bitcoin but we're gonna
spend all has five minutes on my bet ha
I heard it sleeps and to be honest uh so
the first part we did this was like some
Bank was down or what something had her
Instagram went down or something and I
was like you know Bitcoin never goes
down it was probably one of the least
thoughtful things I've ever tweeted in
the sense of like there's a thought that
popped in my head it was kind of like
half funny but true and whatever fired
it off I put my phone down I remember I
like came back I was like oh my god
people like that one really worked so I
did a second time I think like by the
third or fourth time I did it then it
like became a thing versus like this
kind of like repetition becomes a thing
and I forget what sir it might have been
Twitter either no could've been Twitter
maybe was Instagram again like something
went down this is maybe like four five
months later and I didn't tweet and I
had all of these people like tweeting
cough like Bob something I was like all
right this is getting out of hand now
and so just like became this thing which
is like it kind of like the meme is the
message right but Betty Marshall McLuhan
yeah
exactly any facebook employee gets to
learn about on day one I I think people
are surprised at the books that uh that
they're given I remember uh was the same
lesson I think he gives out snow crash
snow crash a big deal Cox was very much
into McLuhan the Klan and the media is
the message yep the medium is the
message
yeah yeah and there was one other one
but those are the two that I remain I
think ready player one is very big on
the VRA our side for sure okay okay UH
one question for you
but in a hold on wouldn't you go up a
coin what I think I would be kind um
well I am you know they can avoid that
question oh gosh I you promised me no
crypto questions you know Joe smirking
in the corner so you definitely can
can't avoid it
well my put I have you know and not
insignificant person is my net worth in
yeah Bitcoin I'm holding you know nicely
hey so I start it's a start i when I had
free time in past years I doubled you
know I don't know when senility abs I
was kind of the first generation of taps
I even treated on many shady you know
Asian trading sites which I know can't
seem to get login back in do well what
do I think so let me tell little in a
personal twist to this so I have a mom
in back in India she lives in Chennai
and every sorry I'm laughing because you
said I have a mom we all do okay you
know a bit older now and you know like
and I in your Indian viewers would
really appreciate this you know have
like any good Indian child I try and
like send money back every once in a
while yeah and it is a painful painful
process like I go through this arcane
you know very well-known companies but
these arcane set of UI with like a crazy
great and it often fails for some real
reasons and you know I just think
there's something very powerful about
like changing and reinventing and
decentralizing all that so you know and
look I am NOT you know a crypto
libertarian I I definitely very
interesting about technology angle I
love for example when batalik vitalic
wrote the state of crypto a few weeks
ago I went
like every single paper you know he was
referring to in there but I think I come
back to you know why why should
Facebook's vibra exist or what is the
promise of Bitcoin coming why is it so
hard to send money to my mom right
because like India and us are both very
civilized countries with weird sort of
this peanuts infrastructure but for me
to even send like a small amount of
money is hard it has so much friction
and then she you know in you know she's
almost 80 now she kind of has to figure
out how do I then convert into actual
money which actually can then go spend
on which sometimes she can't figure it
out so anything which you know and those
barriers shouldn't exist and anything
which can help with that I think so
powerful for my mom you you are hitting
on something that I think the whole
cryptic community has done a really bad
job of actually and if you think about
like a great startup pitch what do they
start with the story here's here's the
state of the world right and this thing
is gonna happen and here's how it's
gonna look in the future I think that
crypto for the most part not not this
isn't true never since but in most part
people like to go to there's this thing
and we're we're gonna change the world
but like explaining what you just did
about here's a prot like a real-life
problem that people have we can fix this
problem with this product right and
here's how that will change I think that
that's been missing a little bit I
actually think that companies that have
been starting the last like three or
four years or doing a much better job of
doing it some of that's because you get
people who have more experience in kind
of the tech world and building companies
etc but they're being teamed up with
people who are like very much crypto
libertarian right in that type of
example you had I listened to a podcast
about calling house off really yeah by
the way his memo fantastic also on my
side I heard a good one my mention of
the podcast the peanut butter memo oh
yes yes
legend MMO but there's something else he
said on the on your part that was super
interesting but he said he oftens into
these conferences and you hear and look
I am a computer science engineer by
background you know like I used to write
paxos algorithms so you know anything
which is about constants or I love all
this stuff right but he's talking about
when he sits in this conference and he's
like but what is the actual problem
you're try
to solve which often to an altar it
seems like some business or management
speak but I like to think about like
back in human terms like I want to send
let's say Bitcoin to my mom you know
Holloway do that how would she
understand it how she actually spend it
at the local store you know around the
corner she has how does all of this work
but as a deal problem because I know
it's how hard it is for me to do that
right now with new karen frandsen first
yeah I I would love him we're going to
make that better yeah look I think it's
gonna happen at some point
right I think it already limit let me
rephrase I think it already is in some
aspects so like on Saturday
it won't settle Bitcoin will do it right
so kind of it's always up right there's
lower fees right okay that's great but
again is the UI perfect no can there be
improvements of course right is there an
education kind of obstacle for people
just understand what is this how do i
transact it India for example very weird
place with crypto right now so is it
legal
yes so I think you have all these like
these incumbents you know who are trying
to feel like what you do with this some
countries obviously no you have the
Chinese government or like leaned in
others are like well we want to take a
wait-and-see approach
no I so that's like another huge factor
yeah
what one question you have for me it's a
lot of fun man oh my thank you I want to
think of a good one okay
hmm okay at this point in 2020 do you
think for 60 days who do you want
Nakamoto to be and do you think the
world should ever find out his/her there
yeah identity so I don't even know if
this controversal anymore I don't want
to know and I think that it one of the
strongest parts of Bitcoin is that we
don't know and we'll likely never know
and the reason to believe you right no I
don't even have 1% of the intelligence
of 1% of the intelligence required to
create something like that he winked at
me you can't feed on he went here in the
park everything did I can't figure out
how to make my cell phone work in the
office
have good cell service don't have
figured that out no but it's just like
yeah I think it was Marty bent was the
first one that I heard say like the
Immaculate Conception right and so if
you think of like if you really boil
down what is money money's a religion
right and that religion is the belief
that when I hand you whatever the
currency is well there's a digital
currency or physical currency whether
it's fiat Bitcoin whatever you accept it
because you and I both believe it has
value right now when you look at why
does it that value except much
explanations whatever but when you think
about that there's not very many wrote
successful religions meaning that
there's people who subscribe to it in
the world where there's a single person
that is alive that everyone looks at and
says that's the leader right now there's
the kind of extremist type you know that
people who end up like all drinking
stuff in like mass suicide all that kind
of crazy stuff right but like a little a
court quote legitimate and I don't even
know if that's the proper way to
describe it but like a mainstream
religion where the person is still alive
who's considered the leader if you look
at fiat currencies there's no single
leader right now there's in many cases
like a central bank that sense will make
the leadership switches out every so
often etc but nobody thinks about like
who's the creator of the US dollar right
it's more of this like facade of an
organization that you can't really touch
or feel
Bitcoin has the same thing and I think
that if it lost that right because it
became very apparent and verifiable like
this is the individual who is Satoshi
Nakamoto or the group especially if
they're still alive a lot of kind of
that magic goes away and so you I don't
think that it's necessarily a fatal flaw
but it definitely causes some problems
and challenges what I don't know is like
there's a lot of people who think Hal
Finney is Satoshi Nakamoto Hal thinnies
passed away so like okay maybe that
still has some of the magic because he's
passed away right but but I don't really
know and so generally like I didn't
matters at this point again if the
person is alive I think it does right
not in the sense of like also in
bitcoins worthless
but like it's Vitalik what are the
persons like out there we know what the
telecast was etherium right like vitalik
spends a lot of time answering questions
about a theorems progress even though
Vitalik is he's incredibly important
he's obviously a the creator if not you
know a creator but it's not only up to a
italic in terms of like he's not writing
all the code bunch of other player but
he's interesting because he's such a
good spokesperson and symbol you just
one of these smartest people that he can
ever encounter yep what if you know he
was somebody who was getting into
scandals all the time going back to a
LeBron example huge it you know what he
wasn't like TMZ you know after a bender
every single night like it would
probably impact through absolutely but
hobbies laughing attendees imagine
metallic well and he's like kind of like
um and he's a little weird right to
describe it but he's not a mythical type
figure but but he's he it people realize
that he's different right
he's obviously incredibly intelligent
the intellectual horsepower that he has
is you know bar none compared to most
people uh he wears like the unicorn
shirts and like just like his whole
mannerisms like you can just tell like
hey that guy's different right and so if
you take that to Bitcoin like I think
that it's just you're 11 years in now
right so you kind of take it away the
part that I do think would be fatal
is if it came out that it was a
government organization hmm so if that
was again really unlikely though given I
mean for them to be on the thumb for the
cypherpunk email list back then it's
this crazier [ __ ] that's happened right
the world the world is crazy but I think
that it's again a verifiable not the
conspiracy theories not the like hey I
stood all these photos and like made a
youtube video and edited it somehow to
make it look like something happened it
was on YouTube it's true very true in
today's day and age but like it was
verifiable that it was an organization
you know associated with a government
accession I think that would be a big
issue and potentially fatal but the
other piece of this actually that's
really interesting to me is at what
level of penetration in the ownership
can be known without it being an issue
so like
forget the Creator take the top ten
holders a Bitcoin I don't know how many
are known but let's say five or six
probably well dude we can't we don't
know the other four what about of the
top twenty the top thirty the top fifty
right like the TIF you're the top 20
holders a Bitcoin like you're probably
holding more than a hundred thousand
Bitcoin like pretty big number right and
so like the whole ethos of Bitcoin would
be that we don't ever find out who those
people are but like if that becomes you
know publicized there's some people
organizations like we've got [ __ ] like
that's bad right not bad because the
assets bad but just like I see now that
there's gonna be people who are upset
that that person owns a lot of this
right right and so I think that there's
kind of like various levels of
fascinating of thought process here but
again like I always fall back then I'm
like I have this theory and startups of
like it's a what is it I think it's the
law of energy I don't know I'm
embarrassed myself right now but
basically things that are in motion stay
in motion things that aren't in motion
you know don't and SERPs are very
similar like if you find a start-up and
they have traction and data points and
like progress and like it's very clear
this isn't just like hey we had a bunch
of ads been like it's working right it's
likely that it's gonna continue working
right for the most part if something is
like stagnant and they can't seem to
like get that inflection point every day
that goes by gets harder and harder to
like all sudden it now starts working
and so I think that Bitcoin probably
more than anything is benefited from
this because it's like 11 years of being
attacked and the media and Technology
and all these different things like it's
still going it's likely that it's gonna
keep going regardless of what we throw
at it including you know who the holders
are or whatever but I think it reflects
though in the charge sort of sense right
it and I think all of these intricacies
and kind of complex questions or like
why people are so fascinated with it
yeah right like it like if you if you
like to think about kind of these
multi-dimensional problems bitcoins like
the perfect thing right you're like oh
wow there's the economic part there's
the technology part there's like the
government and geopolitical components
there's you know all sorts of game
theory involved in economics it's like
Jesus Christ like how
you you can't possibly think through
everything you can't understand it fully
and so there's always something new to
learn just think it's fun that's why
they should subscribe to you I I do
enough shilling up uh people to
subscribe to me and follow me on Twitter
I have one last question for you I
usually don't ask people this oh my god
but you you have a one-year-old it is
the one thing that you've learned as a
new father like what's your one takeaway
from a year of having a little human to
take care of oh my gosh okay that's a
deal hard question out of all the
questions this is the hard one I think
one is it's hard because I think it
don't select all the classical sometimes
the tea answers are true I think it's so
dependent on your unique experience and
it's also so profound that it's hard to
sum up in just like a few words because
such a profound experience in so many
ways what can I say so I I don't know
what some sums it up but I think one of
the things which I always strikes me
about being a dad is it's not often and
I'm gonna sound in a somewhat
sentimental and romantic here and I'm
sure you viously
feel free to roll their eyes it's not
often life that you suddenly have
someone that you're like oh my gosh I
love this person without like expecting
anything with any transaction returns
now if for a lot of us in and your
parents you kind of did that you had
that legend as a kid
but often you know when you find a
partner in you're lucky enough it's like
it happens over time like nobody you
know you know and maybe you're very
lucky but like one day when you like oh
I'm gonna marry this person and that's
it you don't have that but when you have
a child like one is like immediately
your heart and your purse your sense of
who you are expanding I never thought of
myself as a dad or you know somebody who
loved someone that way and I was like oh
my god I don't know this person you
always had a new so well and I'm sure
other fathers listening or parents
listening to it will definitely relate
to that yeah it's really hard to explain
it it's one is the annoying thing where
people have tell me this
before and I was like yes yes I don't
get it but once you kind of get it on
the other side that's one second I think
which is gonna interesting to me is it
puts you in touch with your old own
childhood so every single day
I know remember something I never did
either it's something my own parents did
with me or something
I iEARN word like when I was a kid when
I was a baby about to I used to love
playing with chairs it was a silly thing
every kid has their own thing I've loved
pretend that a chair is a train a bus or
a plane I love playing chess and I'm
gonna see you know my daughter who just
turned one do this I'm like I did
something takes me back man and
something never remembered now because
you don't have really crystal memories I
don't remember this so it kind of makes
you relive your own life may be a part
of your life you're forgotten which is
sub for your sub fibers you know and you
don't room with this and you know under
kind of understand your own parents
better that's kind of this listen will
you become your own parent sometime you
don't understand your parents a lot
better so that's not an expert for me
because I definitely expected in some
ways that you know it's gonna open up
this new set of experiences and you know
your your how you deal this tiny human
being and their you know how to kind of
protect them in this crazy world we live
in but things I didn't expect was it
helps you understand yourself yeah and
your own story and all these expensive
you might've just forgotten so that's
been very unexpected for me I don't know
it's a great answer that's a great
answer
alright listen this might be the most
fun I've had in a while I appreciate it
thank you for come and do it thanks for
having me this is so much fun Shriram k
calm and Shriram k I had Shriram K on
Twitter that was it right but not the
others Shri Rama oh not the other one
that person is evil he's not talked
often all right man we're gonna do this
again
I don't she ate it thank you this is so
much fun thanks for having me